our Prime sponsor uh representative
David Waters he's always a senator
excuse me I promoted you to rep but
that's okay uh Senator Waters has been
works very closely with us and
especially on a number of issues dealing
with either higher education or Career
Tech education which are very important
topics to us and that we really
appreciate his input on these and so
today we're going to be opening up our
our first hearing on SB 24 relative
conferring degree granting authority to
the New England aeronautical Institute
welcome Senator Waters well thank you
very much Mr chairman Mr Vice chairman
members of the committee Senator David
Waters uh District Four to introduce
Senate bill
um 24. some of you may be familiar with
the process we go through to the grant
to confer degree granting Authority the
institution approaches the department of
education does all the paperwork it
needs to do gets the sign off from the
um commissioner and then we have to pass
a bill granting the actual Authority and
then the um the higher education
commission uh does the detailed work on
which degrees are are accepted and and
uh so forth on these programs
um I we've done this most recently for
Signum University but if you look we've
done this uh quite a few times over the
years and I'm particularly interested in
this because we are really growing in
aeronautical industry in in New
Hampshire aeronautical education
programs and uh this is a really good
fit for us the Newland aeronautical
Institute it's a new online institution
based in House New Hampshire it's a
board of um of directors 10 members who
have long experienced in the aviation
um industry it's going to be conferring
a Bachelor of Science in aviation and uh
it is intended for folks who are already
in industry in the workforce or want to
come into the industry and depending on
if you um
are new to the industry it might be a
three and a half year full-time study
program so very thorough ba and then if
you're coming in as you're already been
a pilot for example you can get uh up to
a Year's credit
um for the work that you've done
industry already but that still be a two
and a half year
um two and a half year per program uh
you can look at them on online uh I
think you'll see a very good good plan a
very strong educational
um uh program and so uh I will leave it
at that and be happy to answer such
questions I'm as I may be able to thank
you very much Senator are there
questions from the committee okay
yes represent luno thank you very much
Mr chair thank you very much Senator
waters for bringing this forward have
has some New England aeronautical and
suit operated in in any other state so
so far this would be its first to
receive accreditation okay yeah and it
is it is based in Hollis so it's natural
enough they come do us and uh I think a
lot of
um institutions find New Hampshire very
good to work with and get their
credentialing here because it's well
recognized in other states okay great
thank you and a follow-up to that yes
um you said accreditation but you're
talking about approved degree granting
Authority yeah and and I I think from
the Signum experience
um first comes degree granting Authority
and then comes accreditation is that how
that works okay thank you thank you
are there further questions yes
representative Damon
are there any other institutions in New
England that offer the same
um programs as the New England
aeronautical I don't know
I'm not I'm I'm not I'm not I'm not sure
what the other follow-up questions are
reps and Applebee I'm representative
you're getting promoted yeah we'll we'll
have some do you have anything on that
okay I can guess yeah okay
other questions from the company yes
represent representative cascaden thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question Senator
um it seems I I recall um years ago
there was a Daniel Webster College I
think that wasn't aeronautical
Institution for degreed is this program
mirrored after that or is it anywhere
similar well this is it's this is online
yes I was able to offer uh experiences
experiential part of it
um and uh but in terms of the degree in
offering this bachelor's degree that is
I think a very standard degree in the
way they have outlined it in terms of
specializations within it so I think the
distinction here is it's an online
I have one Senator has a higher
education Commission of course they've
reviewed the application and all uh were
there any recommendations made to them
in regard to bonding Finance aspects of
the of the commission to you know and to
ensure that they don't open up and then
all of a sudden disappear and students
lose and whatever they put into it
well that's your question I can't really
answer it I just know that the Christian
Abu has said that they've done their
process and they have approved
um this this moving forward so I don't I
perhaps Mr Appleby can talk a little bit
more about those aspects of it but uh I
think in a sense like any business those
aspects would be covered that's all part
any further questions from the committee
thank you very much Senator and have a
more date I'll see you later
for sure
okay uh from the Department Steve
Appleby
welcome good morning Mr chair committee
members thank you off the Record Steve
Appleby director of educator support in
higher education at the department of Ed
uh any AI uh presented to the higher
education Commission on May 10th of last
year a proposal to begin start a new
institution in our state it is an online
institution teaching Aviation management
and Logistics
so their initial proposal
came in front of the commission higher
ed commission which is again is a group
of
um appointees with authority over
approving uh programs and institutions
private institutions not publics in our
state so that was May 10th we formed a
Review Committee over the summer and
conducted an in-depth review in August
of 2022 the review team was led by Scott
Stanley Dean of online education at UNH
and had a number of other higher
education members from other
institutions
the uh the committee worked extensively
with the institution and with the
leadership of the institution and made a
number of recommendations the
institution fulfilled those and at the
February higher education commission
meeting
um the committee made a recommendation
to approve the institution and the
commission voted unanimously of course
pending the legislature granting degree
granting approval to approve the
institution there was no dissent
okay thank you Brad very much are there
questions yes representative Miler thank
you Mr chair and thank you for bringing
this forward to us uh could you outline
what the content of the curriculum is
for this program please yes so they seek
to address a need in the marketplace
that exists
um where there are a lack of qualified
managers in the aviation industry right
so they've got and we know about the
lack of Pilots this is not a pilot
program which is different than
um Daniel Webster's program many years
ago was focused on pilots and mechanics
this is focused on management and very
specifically uh you know Airline
managers Logistics managers those types
of roles in the aviation industry
globally and there are this is a global
organization they're hoping to be they
see a real need in Africa and Asia for
these individuals so
um that's the content focus is
management Logistics
just for for information for some of our
committee members here which are are new
we we've uh uh authorized a number of
Institutions frankly all over the world
and including those in Italy and Lebanon
uh because they're they're out of New
Hampshire could you please explain uh
Steve the the a little bit about the
makeup of the commission our College
presidents Etc so that they know who is
doing the review of these applications
certainly
um thank you Mr chair so uh the higher
education commission is a statutory body
that includes
um
essentially all of our four-year public
College presidents so the presidents of
Keene Plymouth Durham Grant State
College for a little longer as well as
the chancellors of both of our higher
education public higher education
systems
two presidents from the community
college system and they rotate over the
years and then there are a number of
spots for private college presidents So
currently the president of New England
College the President of Franklin Pierce
University they serve on the commission
as well and then there are some lay
members
um so it is uh really it's the higher
education leaders from our state on this
Commission
are there yes representative Miler thank
you uh the question was raised I think
by the chair of Senator Waters when you
do your review what's the bonding issue
that you're looking for as relates to
um ensuring that students who engage in
this process uh will not be left high
and dry around that we've had a bill
that came before us on before this
session on this could you just outline
what you look at when you are doing this
review yes indemnification yeah thank
you for the question representative so
um the previous school that came was for
licensed career schools they are
non-degree granting
and in the case of higher education it's
a little different and it's really much
there is no statutory requirement for
bonding in the higher education World
um
but it is taken Case by case in the case
of Sigman University
um the review team felt and the
legislature agreed that bonding would be
wise in in the case of any AI their
finances are extremely strong uh the
review team reviewed their finances in
depth in fact
um one of the review team members is the
CFO from a local college and really
spent a lot of time with their Finance
folks reviewing
um looking at who's investing looking at
bank lines of credit and they are very
well capitalized so no bonding
requirement was put into the
recommendation from the review team
further questions from the committee
yes
um thanks uh to I guess to what extent
does the higher education commission
also consider the um the uh and Senator
Waters mentioned this the um the
experience and membership on their the
um uh the institute's board of directors
and I was wondering what sort of what
sort of experience
um and backgrounds are um are the higher
is the higher education commission
looking for in particular as it relates
to a um to uh Aviation management
Logistics
um
organization great so uh thank you for
the question representative so
um the review team looks at the board of
directors again as part of its overall
review and depending on the makeup of
that board may make recommendations uh
in the case of any AI they came before
the commission initially with their
proposal with a very strong board with
um individuals from the aviation
industry an individual from the global
accreditor of Aviation programs
as well as a number of local leaders
in higher education and politics here in
our state so it was a very strong board
in this case and again
because of the folks involved the the
review team and ultimately the
commission were very comfortable with
the level of experience and expertise
and in fact the president of neaai is Dr
Trent Flores who was the former dean of
the Daniel Webster flight program for
many years and it's also a commercial
pilot so he has extensive ties and
knowledge of the industry
yes representative Balboni thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm really not familiar with
this industry at all so I'm just curious
um since there you say it's not training
Pilots per se what what type of careers
are they being trained to do what kind
of positions would they hold after they
graduated
thank you for the question um so these
are management and Logistics management
positions within
um you know the Aerospace industry so if
you think about a UPS or even American
Airlines they have managers and those
managers need to know
um the aviation industry they're not
just off the shelf
folks right they have very specialized
knowledge for those positions so the
school seeks to train individuals some
of them may be current Pilots looking to
move up but train them for these roles
you know if we think about UPS it's
Logistics is their whole world Amazon
very often and this so there's a real
need for these these types of folks in
these positions so their their
management but a real focus on the
aviation industry
thank you representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question will they be uh I know the last
time we we um we're reviewing a
application like this we asked if they
would receive Pell Grants if they're
going to be open to that um scrutiny
thanks yes um thank you I know they will
not be they are not pursuing regional
accreditation yet there is a process
with neche the regional accreditor for
New England and that process multi-years
in length so in the case of any AI they
will not be accepting financial aid or
Pell Grants
at this time at this time if they choose
to pursue regional accreditation in the
future then they would be that's the
next step right but that that's probably
a five-year process with the accreditor
so it would be quite a ways in the
future
further questions from the committee yes
representative thank you very much Mr
chair
um why uh in this in this process
through granting degree granting
Authority
um why does this come before
accreditation why doesn't accreditation
come first and then degree granting
Authority would seem to be the ultimate
um final step
thank you for that question actually the
accreditors Mandate that this is the
first step
they don't want to talk to a school that
doesn't have state level approval
so for their process at netchi they look
for degree granting authority to be
granted locally before they will
consider someone for accreditation and
that is why we have international
institutions such as the University of
Madiba or Hellenic American because they
had to come and get a state approval
before they could approach in this case
nechi informally me ask the regional
creditors so that it's a it's a it's
just the order of the steps and it's
really driven by the accreditor
ultimately yes yeah so thank you Mr
chair and so have there been
um I guess institutions where where
where the legislature has has granted
degree granting Authority who have then
failed to uh to acquire the the the
uh
thank you for that question I believe so
I spent 10 years on the higher education
commission and I don't recall it
happening during that time so going back
almost 20 years I don't recall it in
recent memory okay so and just so just
to follow up on that and I I'm not going
to get into a big Signum type of type of
thing but signal thank you well I think
was the last
um uh organization I see that their
presidents on on the board of directors
of this organization here but um but
just wondering have they successfully
then uh received accreditation and um
and and have begun uh granting degrees
so they are working with an accreditor
currently they're in the accreditation
process again it's a multi-year
multi-step process
um typically around five years in length
and they are working through that
process and meeting the Milestones as
they go
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you are there any other pink cards on SB
uh 25.
24 excuse me
not seeing it we will close this hearing
and in five minutes we will start the
next
next hearing
okay thank you
yeah
that's the next two Wednesdays
yeah I don't think we're going to be
scheduling here at that time okay yeah
foreign
so good morning again to all our public
and for the committee members here in
the public we are now going into the
hearing on Senate bill 215. this is
relative to nursing certification
requirements
and I'd like to welcome
Senator Lou dalessandro
thank you very much Mr chairman that
it's an array of characters I see yeah
yeah right in front of us a wonderful
group I want to tell you that in 1872 I
was elected to the to the House of
Representatives and I served on the
committee on education but that was my
first assignment and it was a completely
unique experience for me you know being
my first time as as a legislator and it
was a great committee and I don't know
if they still have it the business year
but we had our end of the session party
for the committee which I thought was a
great camaraderie and great
relationships are established in the
legislature and it was always a good
idea so first of all thanks so much for
allowing me to come before you to speak
on blank on my legislation it's a
privilege to be here and uh thank you so
much for taking the time
the bill is is a very simple one
it's an important bill at the right time
and I must say that out of full
disclosure my daughter-in-law is a
school nurse she's the school nurse at
Cochran high school and prior to that
was a school nurse at Pittsfield High
School
as writtenly as recently as last year a
school could hire a school nurse with an
associate's degree in nursing if the
nurse goes out to complete a bachelor's
program within six years of the date of
hire
however given the third set of the
current law this ended on July 1st 2002
2022. this bill reinstates this
important pathway that was previously
available to School nurses in schools
hiring nurses during a time of events
Workforce pressure at a nursing shortage
Senate Bill 215 is the result of nurses
in Manchester who first brought this to
my attention working together with the
New Hampshire school Nurses Association
and I might say that all of the parties
were in concert with regard to this
piece of legislation all of the parties
we brought them together and they came
up with a with the right solution
it allows schools to hire school nurse
holding an associate's degree but still
recognizes the continuing importance of
the bachelor's degree
this is because school nursing is now a
high specialty in nursing the knowledge
base you need is very expensive it
continues to grow and evolve
this is also consistent with the current
practice in acute care settings which
advertise BSN prefer it in other words
nurses hide without a BSN are simply
required to enroll in a bachelor's
program
but again this bill also reflects
Workforce realities this is why August
25th 2019 is included is included is
because uh different requirements Supply
to nurses had already before August 21st
2019. this is a reasonable approach that
protects our school children as all of
us know uh
School nursing has become a very very
very difficult job and I can tell you
that out of personal experience my my
daughter-in-law goes in at eight in the
morning and is busy until the closing of
school on a daily basis and they are
really required
uh to do a lot more than they just
talked to an individual student thing
it's it's a very very difficult job a
lot of pressure and uh
this bill takes care of a problem it
allows us to move forward it retains to
be I said it it it allows us uh like in
the city of Manchester to have arids it
gives them an opportunity to get the BSF
so Mr but with that I would appreciate
your support of this piece of
legislation as it's good for for New
Hampshire it's good for the schools and
it's good for the nurses thank you thank
you very much Senator D'Alessandro are
there questions for the senator
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question thank you for being here
Senator I'm just curious so it expired
in July of 22.
um do we know what percentage of
associate degree nurses actually went on
to get their bachelor's
uh that's great great question I don't
have those stats but I believe that
somebody must have them I don't have the
before lead but I I would think that the
the pressure to get a BSN is really
it's really existed and people are
moving in that in that direction and we
got some very very super BSN programs
here in New Hampshire today is office a
wonderful BSN program I think Rivier
University and of course the University
of New Hampshire uh office and we
expanded our capacity at the University
of New Hampshire by 50 students were
allowed to get 50 more so I'm sure that
that process is moving uh in a rapid
Direction I put okay thank you for
taking my question thank you you're
welcome supporting skilled nurses thank
you representative Damon
I do have a question I want to also just
add to your list of institutions in the
state offering RN programs Colby SAR
college and River Valley Community
College
um and Colby sorry does the BSN program
my question is where the basis of the
six-year time frame other than the
pre-existing law it seems like a long
time
it's their
any explanation of why it's that long to
get into the bachelor's I I think
others could give you testimony as to
why why that's why that was probably I
think it wasn't a combination
uh it it seemed it seems to be and I do
appreciate the fact that Colby soya has
a has a program they're working in
conjunction with Hitchcock that was
Hitchcock in that it just shows you the
dramatic need we have for nurses I mean
it's it's a very it's it's one of the
real
problems that we have in our in our
schools not only do we need
be nurses but we we also need social
workers to be honest with you that the
nurses are being uh being asked to do
all of that work at the present time and
that's way that's Way Beyond what they
were what they brought out for just a
few years ago we put a four-year degree
program in the PSU as well and that
program is overloaded with applications
there's just so many seats available
that's the problem
represents
okay thank you for taking my question
I'm familiar with the program the
nursing program at saying he's because I
I taught there and had some of the
nurses for my students
and it's a very rigorous full-time
program and so I've imagined the others
are too I'm just left wondering how a
nurse at a school working at a school
would be able to
um go to a program like that or uh just
a concern I don't know if you have any
feedback on that okay
could you kind of explain to me what
you're what you're query my question is
that the so you have a nurse at a school
working at a school with an Associate
who then has to get a bachelor's degree
in six years but how
I know that some of these programs I'm
familiar with was
so regimented their schedule like how I
none of them had jobs outside so are
there other programs that would address
this I don't see how they'd be able to a
program like that which I don't know if
Riviera's like that but how with the
logistics of this work of them getting
into a program and balancing it the
education with their job yeah good point
it's a really good point and I know the
the program at St a is as rigorous and
it's quite it's called Pac that it and
they don't have an extension program
which is a a little bit problematic I
taught at CDs for a number of years so I
I could tell you that I appreciate the
nurses there but it's it's not easy it's
not easy you have to find a place that
oftens the courses it does it to move
forward so you know that could it's
that's it's an emphasis of the value of
continuing education and how important
it is that uh programs are are available
that
people can access don't know don't know
the full type basis but on a part-time
basis it could could get their degree
further questions just represent
McDonald thank you and good morning good
morning this bill has a fiscal note but
then turning to the fiscal note it says
this bill will have no impact on revenue
or expenditures so why is our fiscal
note thank you very much for the
question I know sometimes we ask for
fiscal notes because it's uh unclear but
that this has no physical impact at all
all right thank you you're welcome
yeah the fiscal note issue is an issue
right that's an issue there's no money
in it at all right right you know later
there he needs to be money in it but uh
represent Allison oh thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for being here Senator I'll
see you thank you uh a question about
capacity and I guess that goes back to
the question around
how many people do we have who have
Associates degrees who now would be
covered under this I mean all the
programs I'm familiar with are packed as
a matter of fact the little story that
valedictorian from Dover High School uh
was not accepted in the nursing program
UNH because she didn't have a high
enough grade point average and that's a
very competitive if we have significant
numbers of people right how where are
they going to go and how are they going
to get in I guess that's my question
well it's a great question and I think
let me let me try to give you an answer
that that it boggles my mind we had a
wonderful nursing program at New
Hampshire hospital that we discontinued
it we actually trade psychiatric nurses
at New Hampshire hospital there's a
tremendous debate for psychiatric nurses
but all of a sudden we don't have any
programs
every hospital this state
used to have a nurses program
I remember Elliot's program I I think
maybe Sacred Heart and Notre Dame had
this well he discontinued those programs
out of out of I think
maybe it was an economic issue and as a
result we we have the Genesis we're the
creation of our own problem
and as a as a result of this we'll we've
got to build and uh we've got to get
things going now we did great this
legislation did great work when we gave
the University of New Hampshire
additional funds
to create 50 boy slots for nurses now
that's that that's that's a step forward
and that program is highly competitive
you're you're exactly right it's highly
competitive
and uh
even outstanding students outstanding
students every competition with one
another they can't get in
the time to expand the nursing programs
is here uh it uh we've got to do board
now Saint Joseph's instituted an
associate degree program in nursing a
few years ago St Joseph's Hospital
and that again that was part of a of a
situation where they discontinued a
program it would have been reinstated
that reinstated it because of the the
demonstrated the
uh but but but clearly uh the the needs
they we need spaces and we got to think
about we have to think about that
thank you you're welcome we have we have
a number of pink cards here from The
Nurses Association for the School nurses
from various organizations
every one of these cards is in support
so if we have some technical questions
that are specific to the Nurses
Association we have folks here that can
answer those for us hopefully
so are there any other questions for
ours represent senator dalzandra who
yeah we think an awful lot about you and
you're you're just wonderful and you've
done a lot for the state we certainly
appreciate it even if you are UNH grab
not amazing well you know we beat made
that's all I can say repeat me that's
not the way it used to be in baseball
you know what I know it you're right
about that yeah
okay anything else of the senator thank
you very much thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you for the courses
always welcome great to see all of you
thank you
uh we're gonna have Nancy Wells next
from New Hampshire school Nurses
Association
and this building's not very handicapped
have a good one
welcome
thank you chairman
um
Health coordinator and I'm here in
support of chief of the billstone field
215 as it's been amended
it's been around the school district
into high University including associate
degree into the division of the nurse
achieves yes
press the silver button
is that better that's better thank you
sorry
um uh and the reason we use the six
years is because it's two certification
cycles and for some of our nurses trying
to go back to school it does take a
while to go uh while you're working so I
hope that answers that question for you
this does give the school district the
flexibility to find and hire a nurse
with the assurance that the nurse will
be achieving the skills in education
essential for this specialty practice of
school nursing
today's school nurse is working in a
very fast-paced multi-discipline setting
responsible for meeting the needs of all
children including the increased number
of students with multiple complex
physical and mental health issues this
requires the nurse to have strong skills
in clinical care and critical thinking
advocacy leadership and the ability to
match your practice to the ever-changing
evidence as new research emerges this
means not only can the nurse provide
immediate and care and procedures for
students with asthma with seizure
disorders with anaphylaxis and multiple
physical conditions but also includes
the planning with School staff
and teachers how to keep students safe
and successful in their classroom and
fully participate in school activities
the nurse also must work with
local Health Care Providers the state
agencies including the division of
Public Health the division of child and
Youth and Family environmental services
and unfortunately the Homeland Security
in this day and age as well as other
service organizations within the
community
Bridging the Two Worlds of Health Care
and education the nurse must be able to
speak the language of Education as well
as integrate students Health needs into
that education mayor
the Baccalaureate nursing education
provides specific coursework in
Pediatrics and in public health both a
core Specialties within the school
nursing specialty
as content areas I'm not emphasized in
the associate level programs with a
structured semester-long clinical
experiences that we find in the
Baccalaureate education
we need to continue to guarantee
excellent School nurses for our students
for our parents our administrators and
our full School communities this is in
keeping with national standards as well
as area state standards for professional
nursing across all practice areas as a
matter of fact some of our local
surrounding states are now require a
master's degree for School nurses
the importance of qualified School
nurses was no more imperative than it
was during the past few years with the
pandemic and our communities really do
need to be assured that all School
nurses can provide the quality nursing
services that our students and schools
deserve thank you thank you very much
are there questions yes represent Tanner
and representative Iowa thank you I want
to thank you and all the School nurses
in New Hampshire for the effort you've
put through through covid and after
covid trying to get these kids to you
know get back in school and stay in
school it's really been important I'd
like you to speak a little bit about
um the role of the school nurse
particularly in our rural areas how
they're they're dealing a little bit
differently than perhaps the nurses in
Manchester and Nashua where hospitals
and doctors are readily available
school nurse is frequently the primary
Person Medical person that families and
children actually see so they're the
ones who actually do triage as to what
kind of Health Care that we might have
to have plus they've had the connections
with the health care facilities that may
be surrounding and making sure that we
have those uh students with a clear path
to get to this need the help the care
that they need so yeah it's different
thank you represent miler
well thank you for being here it's
always nice to see you hi Mel
um a question I guess one I have we've
we've had the issue of Licensing of
nurses before this committee before
and there is always a hesitation of
watering down the qualifications to
become a school nurse my sense is is
that based upon your testimony you feel
that this is not a watering down but
it's basically trying to address the
particular needs so that's my first
question the second question if you
could outline for the committee
um based upon your years of experience
as a school nurse how has it changed
what you know when you came in to be a
school nurse years ago to what the
actual responsibilities are what has
been some of the changes that have taken
place so those two questions if you
could answer those thank you okay
um the certification itself is
definitely something that will make sure
that there's a guarantee because we've
now established some specific skills
that we need to have
what's changed is I started my career as
an emergency room nurse and I thought I
was golden walking through the door but
the problems aren't just first aid they
aren't just I'm recognizing a hot
appendix or recognizing a broken bone is
really looking at this all the social
determinants of Health that we have that
impact this child coming to school can
they sleep do they eat can they
um do they have health issues that are
related to mental health issues
um so that's kind of what's changed
um and it's important to realize that
the school nurse is part of a team if we
work with our social workers we work
with our school guidance counselors and
we work with teachers as well as our
school administrators is really a lot
more complicated the other issue we have
is we have children that are that are
recovering from being in a NICU and they
usually have some kind of sequela which
would mean they may very well have
seizure disorders they may have
developmental issues I now we have to do
catheterizations in school I have to do
colostomy care I have to do tracheostomy
care so it's a lot more complicated than
um certainly the first days that I was a
school nurse
yes representing portiello
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and it's similar to
the one I asked the senator so perhaps
you have more familiarity with where
will these nurses who are working at
these schools uh where will they go for
this education a lot of these programs
like I mentioned I was feeling I'm
familiar with with one of them a very
rigorous full-time so how will you
accommodate the need for for the
education there are multiple programs
and even in the state and there are also
some there online with as appropriate
clinical assignments as well that are
planned so School nurses can do that I
personally went back to school for nurse
practitioner as I was working full-time
so it can be done
um so like Granite State College has a
good program it takes you know the
associate degree nurse and and has
coursework it's one of the reasons we
looked at two certification Cycles which
would be the six years because
um if you're working and you're working
in particularly if you're a working
parent it's really difficult to get in
all of those credit hours in a very
short period of time so that's kind of
where this but there's several programs
around so
yes represent dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just to follow up on
that um
life happens what happens if it's six
years you're not done
um I don't have an answer for that
um uh that would be the decision of the
Department of Ed in terms of continuing
yes representative thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question as
a former nurse myself I know we've been
working long and hard encouraging nurses
to achieve their bachelor's degree I
mean it's been 30 years since I
graduated and we're still having us the
same conversation
um do you think six years is long enough
how many associate degree nurses do we
have actually working as School nurses
and will we achieve this goal in six
years
it helps number one I hope so
um I do not have the number of how many
nurses we have that are associate
degrees versus that but we can get that
information for you
um right now I think we have more
Baccalaureate nurses than we have
associate degree nurses and we kind of
looking at this because we're having
studied to have a nursing shortage we
want to get ahead of it so
further questions yes represent Allison
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I want to piggyback on the the
issue of how many somebody's got to know
how about how many
nurses or associate nurses are working
now that would then come under the the
new legislation and that becomes
important I think from my perspective
because we got a bottleneck if there are
100 associate nurses out there who are
Associates and they all have to get a ba
within six years in almost all of the
programs in the state have an acceptance
rate of about five to ten percent with a
90 rejection rate where do these what
are the applications for these people
follow let alone
having the capacity there how do they
what you know how do you determine
whether this school nurse goes to the
top of the list ahead of everybody else
or in the middle I mean they're just
questions I think about implementation I
I think it's a great build I just think
that that in my mind
capacity is really huge here and I
understand how much time was spent and
effort was spent adding 50 slots to UNH
but if we're talking about significant
numbers of people here that there's a
there's an issue that has to be dealt
with that's all that's a good question
um I think it's important to remember
that most of our nurses and across the
state have already been grandfathered or
already been certified so this is for
thank you
uh represent Cornell thank you thank you
for taking my question so when you said
grandfather that it says all School
nurses hired after August 2019 2019. so
if they were hired before that they're
all set if they were grandfathers okay
thank you very much okay we have a
number of others that I want to come out
and testify too on this bill
um so and we do have the department here
as well and some of those questions uh
you know that art just mentioned might
be Hansel there if not we can go right
to the colleges themselves and go to the
nursing programs and get that response
thank you very much
thank you very much chair Ladd I
appreciate the opportunity to speak and
I just wanted to thank this committee I
know that this Committee in particular
has done a Herculean amount of work this
uh this year so far and I was very
impressed by how much went through the
house last week and I just wanted to say
thank you for all the work because I
know it's a lot
uh my name is Sean Parr I'm on the
Manchester School Board where I sit on
the policy committee and chair the
education legislation committee today
I'm speaking on behalf of the Manchester
School Board which has authorized me to
advocate in support of allowing school
districts to hire School nurses with an
associate's degree as you heard pursuant
to changes in this law that took effect
on July 1st 2022 the Manchester school
district is no longer able to hire
nurses with an associate's degree in
nursing into a school nurse 1 position
as outlined in the New Hampshire
education regulations the current
version of RSA 200.29 requires the
district to hire new School nurses with
a bachelor's degree which effectively
nullifies our school nurse 1 position
the district has many valued School
nurses that were grandfathered under an
older version of the law and that
provide excellent care to our students
and the district is already experiencing
great difficulty in hiring School nurses
now
sb215 will allow us to consider
applicants with associates degree and
will better enable us to remain police
staffed with a team of School nurses
across our 21 schools let me ask for
your support of this bill and thank you
very much for your consideration
I do have a question for you Sean um has
the Manchester School District had to
get into the business of contracted
services for various agencies to provide
further questions representative parano
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question what is a school
nurse one position assuming there's
different levels sure so the school
nurse one position was that the
associates level school nurse position
there and so that's what we cannot hire
for we had a slot for that as a as one
type of hire that could could be done
within the district there and so above
that would be the bachelor's level nurse
school nurse 2 Etc yeah
yes representative Damon
thank you Mr chair I'm actually
following up on your question so
in the need to use contract nurses I'm
asking you to State the obvious what's
the cost impact of that I I'm not sure I
have the exact cost impact but it is
much more expensive yes and it is it is
a big burden for our district there's no
doubt there's no doubt I think we're at
the on the order of seven or eight
nurses in that category if I remember
correctly
yes
so if it's seven or eight out of 21
schools that each have at least one
nursing position you're telling us that
a third or so our contract members we do
need to hire School nurses yes yeah yeah
that's happening all over the state
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair you think you've
taken my question uh is there any in
your school district is there any
monitoring of the progress that these
nurses are making so that all of a
sudden year six you know it's like oh
gosh I'm not going to be able to do it I
mean is there a mentoring
support system for these nurses I
believe there is support uh I'm I'm not
aware of a monitoring at this point
there uh so this will be for new hires
they're since 2019 there and I'm not I'm
not I don't have that number for you in
terms of how many we have in that
category that would need to be monitored
to make sure they finish within six
years
yeah okay thank you
thank you thank you for taking my
question it's kind of big
have you you you have had
um associates degree nurses in the past
in your school and we still do and you
still do do they do a fine job if you
had any problems with them no no
problems they're excellent is there a
reason then that they need to get their
bachelor's if they're doing fine with
the associates
well I think that refers to the kind of
30-year process that's been referred to
a couple times that there's been an urge
to uh have nurses have that bachelor's
credential there and I'm afraid I can't
speak to the history of that as well as
perhaps those behind me there but but
from your experience
from my experience the nurses have them
as a July 1st 2022 all School nurses
hired in the state of New Hampshire must
have a bachelor's degree or higher and
be certified through the Department of
Education while the state does not
require School nurses to be schools to
be staffed with nurses is of course
preferred to having an administrator
with little or no medical experience
and especially with the increase in
complex medical needs of students the
trouble is school districts are
struggling to hire nurses in the
requirement of a bachelor's degree is a
contributing factor to that problem
I believe that the original law was well
intentioned but misguided for a
multitude of reasons and I believe my
person as part of my research I reviewed
the NCLEX Pass rates from 2014 to 2021.
for those who may not know that's a
national exam for those who wish to work
as a nurse associate and bachelor's
programs in New Hampshire are equivalent
regarding their Pass rates over the
eight-year span with associate degree
programs averaging a total 92.47 pass
rate and bachelor's programs totaling an
average 91.51 pass rate this indicates
statistically no difference in the
quality of nurses coming out of each
program
I also believe that the law as is can
have unforeseen consequences of being
discriminatory against many in society
such as single parents and those who
live in low-income areas or come from
low-income families who cannot afford
the tuition to a school with a
bachelor's program
some will say that my advocacy financial
literacy and research abilities are
proof of the benefits of requiring
nurses to obtain a bachelor's degree I
must respectfully disagree on the
grounds that these individuals did not
know me prior to my being enrolled for
my bachelor's including my many years of
advocacy and fundraising for the Youth
of Manchester through non-profits into
the shortage a lot of work is available
to negotiate their starting step and
somebody coming in say with a bachelor's
degree could could argue that you should
stop me at step five uh some like that
further questions yes representative
Luna thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much Mr Durkin for uh for
your testimony this morning I know
there's probably others um that may
follow that that may be in position
answer this question as well but but but
I think you you may be as well I think
first it would it would sort of wrap a
question about Statewide how many
positions are are unfilled but but I
want to tie it to a comment you you you
made which is you appreciated the
Senate's quick action on this we've got
about two two and a half months left of
the um of the school year
um would would quick action be able to
to have any impact on on school
districts and their students
um in what's left of uh of the school
year and how could you quantify that uh
that's a very good question and I I I I
I guess the way it may be able to help
is you we are coming up you know also to
the end of the the school year too so
the sooner this legislation is in place
uh the sooner they can start acting on
hiring even not for this year but for
next year a lot of School departments do
their hiring at the end of the school
year or the start date for September uh
so the sooner the better definitely
thank you I know you're from the Mass
area yes sir um are we in competition
with what's going on with schools down
just over the line folks live on either
side and they go back and forth for work
are we seeing some of our nurses going
to Massachusetts due to the fact that
they may be paying you know a person
with a bachelor's more than 30 bucks an
hour or something such as that I I don't
have any hard figures on that but I'm
sure I'm sure you are sure it is
definitely a employee's market right now
and you know going back to the uh even
within Massachusetts there is in uh
wages that are being offered I'll go
back to the example of my sister and
Lowell where they had over the past
couple of years had lost about 10 nurses
to other Massachusetts school districts
because the wage levels were so low and
we've since been able to address that
and get them up to speed but the up to
par but the the damage was done in that
City anyway
thank you further questions not seeing
any thank you very much thank you uh I'd
like to invite Paula and address some of
the things that have already been
brought up uh thank you for having me
here today
um it's a pleasure to see you all
and I'll be very brief in my own
testimony uh the New Hampshire school
Nurses Association supports the
amendment to SB 215 the amendment is
what will allow school districts to hire
Associates prepared nurses with a
condition that they enroll in a bachelor
of nursing program and complete it
within six years this should immediately
increase the number of nurses available
to interview for school nursing
positions and we know that the nursing
shortage is here to stay for the
immediate future we hope that you will
pass this bill as it was amended
now there are several other points that
I would like to bring up after hearing
other people testify
there was a question about who is
following these nurses
and being sure that they are meeting the
criteria and and a simple answer to that
is the certification board for the
Department of Education every school
district should be monitoring the
continuing education that a nurse takes
and applying that toward their
certification board when their renewal
comes up it's actually each School
District that then approves the person
for the certification board the
um question came up about not enough
bachelor's nursing programs in the state
we do a pretty good job of connecting
our School nurses at our conferences
with many many online programs who are
scrambling to get these nurses enrolled
into their program for example we have
Elms College who will be at our
conference this Saturday and nurses will
have a chance to talk to them about
their online programs these online
schools are in regular touch with us
they are very aware that New Hampshire
has recently passed the caveat that
their Associate's degrees nurses must
continue in their education and they're
scrambling to get the business so to
speak
the um
person that spoke from the Manchester
School Board I hopefully I have answered
the question of who's monitoring these
School nurses
um
let's see let's address uh Manchester
struggling to hire and we do know from
past history and we do know from a very
comprehensive salary survey that our
association has done that Manchester is
far below unfortunately other school
districts so Manchester is losing their
nurses to other school districts are
they crossing the border into
Massachusetts possibly Massachusetts
requires a bachelor's upon hire and has
for quite some time and they encourage
all of their School nurses to then go on
and get their masters
the pay in Massachusetts yes I I live in
a Border Town I've looked into it many
times and in fact worked part-time for
one of their uh school districts during
the summer which paid significantly more
A continuing education once these nurses
uh are in a bachelor's program the fact
that they're in that bachelor's program
does count toward their continuing
education and the continuing education
that they have to complete for their
nursing license is 30 hours every two
years the certification board at the doe
requires 15 hours
every year so they can use their
continuing ed for both of those
um
mandates that they must meet so there's
no additional continuing education that
they have to be meet in order to keep
their certification it's the same hours
that they would have had for their
license and the nice part about that is
that the oplc and the Board of Nursing
does no tracking of uh continuing
education hours now we've got the school
districts who through the certification
board should care about the continuing
education of their nurses and be
monitoring that just like they do their
teachers
uh do we need quick action uh on passing
this bill absolutely because school
districts are looking and hiring now uh
for next school year we have uh
currently eight uh nurses who have
reported someone who's retiring as far
as schools that are without a nurse we
still do know that Hinsdale has been
without a nurse all year
and the nurse that was in that position
uh reports to me that she had to leave
the position because of low pay she just
couldn't make ends meetings a single
mother you know bringing up her kids she
feels very bad thank you and thank you
again to all the School nurses for all
they've been doing you know over coveted
and afterwards we know that and we've
heard that both Associates and Bachelors
take the same RN exam and and are both
highly qualified to be nurses could you
speak a little bit to the specialty of
of school nursing
that means over and above the
associate's degree or maybe it doesn't
so could that's one of the questions
that we've had yeah let's look for
example the associate degree nurse yes
they take the same uh test and they pass
the same test it allows them entry into
the nursing profession so if they go to
work in a hospital and decide that the
oncology unit that they rotated through
during their Nursing
education if they decide that I want to
be an oncology nurse they take more
courses they take more courses there's
actually a certification in oncology
nursing that they can get through the
American Nurses Association if they so
choose many many hospitals will set up
someone to help nurses with what what
continuing education do you need for us
to call you an oncology nurse and to
move you up the ranks so the same in in
school nursing although the
certification Department did not want to
get involved in developing courses for
school nursing we do have
um
there is a national certification that
they can take through the national board
of certification for School nurses but
that's not being required uh there are
elms college has developed a master's in
school nursing just for the School
nurses of New Hampshire and they'll be
implementing that this this school year
for the nurses that want to move up but
do they need uh and want further
education they absolutely should and and
we would hope that the school districts
would take those nurses under their
wings and say you know we'd like to see
you take some college courses in public
health or this Arena or that Arena
because the um since inclusion happened
which has been many many years the role
of the school nurse just keeps expanding
and expanding and we talk to our school
nurses we'd like them to be leaders
within the school because Administration
doesn't know what they don't know and
they need to be at the table and speak
up and say we'd like to see this or you
know I've got some resources I can bring
in a vaccination clinic if that's what
you want I've got some resources that I
can bring in for your teachers for
continuing education they need to know
more about diabetes they need to know
more about the health situations that
are going to affect a child's learning
so they really are a liaison between
the parent the school the teachers the
administration
um
it's a it's a specialty practice for
sure we do have several more pink cards
here so are there any yes representative
yeah thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much um uh Ms McKinnon
for uh for being here again for for uh
for these bills and um and I I and also
I I would thank you and everybody I
think for a very good a well done
collaborative effort I think it's great
when we see legislation coming forward
that's built this way that clearly moves
things forward for all the grant all
Granite Staters
um but I wanna I'm and I you I'm
thinking you may be the right person
asked there may be others that that that
could help answer this but I want to
sort of take this more through an
operational
um question I was on a school board for
12 years and um and so I certainly saw a
lot of collective bargaining agreements
and and things like that and and um and
from time to time the superintendent
would uh would would
um be in a position where where they
needed to hire let's say a teacher with
an ALT certificate or something that
didn't quite fit the
um the normal practice but I'm wondering
with with
um with certainly many collective
bargaining agreements in place right now
that may not have an Associates track
um on them is there is there a means for
a superintendent to to hire an associate
level nurse and and have them on or off
the um the collective bargaining
agreement or is there additional
legislation that would need to be sort
of taken up in conjunction with this to
provide that sort of emergency
um of capability until uh either the the
CBA could be reopened or renegotiated
okay when we did our salary survey we
looked at every single contract in the
state and specifically we looked for its
recognition clause and in the vast
majority of
um of contracts that we looked at the
nurses were recognized in that clause
which then meant that they were under
the teacher contract that does not mean
that they had to be paid as a teacher
and we found about
15 percent of the nurses across the
state were in a separate
pay category but we have found since the
legislation in 2016 and certification
came on board that many nurses
renegotiated those contracts and got put
on teacher pay at the bachelor level
does that answer your question yeah so
so partially in the in this case you
know the the the nurse may be coming on
an associate's level working towards a
bachelor's level and and I'm just
wondering in the in these collective
bargaining agreements that you've
reviewed if and and in Hopkinton where I
was on the board the the nurses were
um I think this English like whatever
electives you have to take to us I'm not
familiar with all of them and
professionalism in nursing I think is
one of them sometimes there's a there's
a
like different roles that nurses can
have
it's a you know varied thank you
thank you very much thank you the last
card which we have is Steve Appley from
the Department of Education
um we have a a number of other
communities are looking at shortage
shortage teachers we're looking at the
higher education committee to looking at
prep teacher preparation institutions as
well as teacher preparation institutions
here in the state but Steve I do have
one question for you that's come to my
obviously there has to be some way of
you know like we have the higher
education commission here which we've
talked about you know you know we
authorize but they're approved by the
higher commission you know to function
as a four-year institution in our state
uh well how are we certifying or
understanding that
this online program is
cutting the mustard
thank you for the question uh chair uh
for the record Steve Appleby director of
educator support and higher education at
the department of Ed
um so in the nursing world you know
there are uh there's a subject matter
and the Name Escapes me a creditor that
credits nursing programs Nationwide
right that our colleges participate in
so
um and additionally the Board of Nursing
is very very involved with these
programs right they have to maintain
past rates uh for their graduates
in not all instances does the higher ed
commission have to approve an individual
degree program for example our public
colleges the higher education commission
has no jurisdiction over the public
colleges so we look to the accreditor
very typically to maintain the quality
piece
so is that a net you like organism so we
have institutional creditors such as
nachi the Western commission uh the
states other there are I believe it's
five Regional accreditors around the
country that accredited institutions but
then we also have subject matter of
creditors that so for example
um UNH the Public School of Business has
an accreditation from the business
accreditor right that's very high level
in Ed prep Cape exists which accredits
teacher prep programs educated
preparation programs so there are
there's institutional level
accreditation and then there's subject
matter accreditation
okay all right I think we're going to
get down in the weeds too far here but
um we need to look at that yeah can I
just share some numbers I heard the
question come up several times go ahead
um just some some quick information uh
for the committee uh there are currently
approximately 488 licensed School nurses
through the Department of Education
and it's important to note that every
one of these individuals also holds a
board of nursing license so they hold
two licenses within that 488 we have 32
currently
and here as we can tell that hold only
an associate's degree
so the question came up before I think
from representative Ellison about how
many we talking about it's 32
individuals currently
at most it could be less definitely
tracks with the Manchester District's
position title the school nurse one
license we have 32 individuals who hold
it and those are individuals who
attain that license because they only
had an associates they may have since
gotten a bachelor's but not renewed
and the effect of this legislation will
allow those 32 if they haven't completed
to renew
currently today when they expire
and they only have an Associates there
is no path to renewal so this
legislation would give them another six
years
the idea of the number of seats are
available either at Plymouth State UNH
Saint anselms or other that are
available and how many of those seats
are occupied by out of state students I
do not
I do not have the information we could
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you see the effective date
of being problematic like right now
school districts are hiring so if we've
got to wait once it's passed then you
gotta wait another 60 days is that
almost too late for the 23-24
I I think from a hiring perspective it's
probably less problematic than for the
32 individuals who are going to expire
potentially some number of them expire
this June 30th and they will not be able
to renew that might be the more
immediate issue
okay thank you so we approve this
effective signage
yeah
good question represent cordial
thank you Mr chair and I have a very
quick question you Quantified the
number of uh licensed nurses and how
many have Associates but we keep hearing
about this shortage is there any way you
can quantify that
of how many positions need being filled
that could be filled by these associate
level nurses yeah we we do not have that
information
not seeing any other questions thank you
very much thank you
with that I'm going to close this
hearing
we're at 11 10 we haven't had a break
some people been sitting here for a long
time
Senator Ward I know you're here to go
with the next one Madam nurse
um
are you okay if we take about a five
minute break here
pardon me okay thank you very much we're
foreign
I think we're about ready to reconvene
and I believe our next bill is uh house
excuse me Senate bill
um 266 and uh Senator Ward
good morning Mr chair and the members of
the committee
I am Ruth Ward I am a senator represent
Senate District eight now 20 Townsend
I'm not gonna repeat them
this build is being introduced on behalf
of the New Hampshire Department of
Education to make some technical
Corrections
the IT addresses two areas of law
State assessments
this bill clarifies the Statewide
student Assessment program including the
state's obligation to administer an
assessment in grades 3 through 8 and 11.
State accountability for an adequate
education this bill clarifies the
criteria for an adequate education this
bill removes language duplicative or
contradictory to the federal every
student succeeds Act
this bill combines two areas of
legislation which is confusing in its
current format when read individually
this bill moves laws to a new section
that are currently housed in adequate
education but they should be in their
own section of law
that is this sentence of this bill and
there will be people from the doe who
thank you I would just in terms of your
comments
um are you indicating that some of our
statutes might be confusing
you said that not I
a good response thank you uh
representative Miler
um thank you for being here Senator Ward
the question I would have how much time
did the Senate education committee spend
on this particular reviewing this
particular bill is 26 pages so it's a
major it's a major piece here so how
long what kind of time did you guys have
in your committee to look at this I
don't think I ever put my clock on and
message how long time it takes to read I
tried to read everything and then I go
through it and then we discuss it and I
think the Department of Education has
been tremendously helpful and it's uh
explaining why things need to be done
for the questions from the committee
I don't see any other pink cards up here
but um perhaps we could call up
our friends from the Department for uh
good morning for the record Caitlin
Davis from the Department of Education
uh Nick Green New Hampshire Department
out and give the committee a little
history of why this bill exists
um I think you use or technical
assistance and that's exactly what this
bill is is its technical assistance to
the department
um in what we think we need to implement
these programs
um so about uh two years ago so in the
last state budget the department had
requested a position to implement the
state accountability system required in
RSA 193e
193e and 193 H
those uh those programs the ibass and
the pbas and the state accountability
have not had a specific position that's
overseen that work in a period of time
at the department so we had requested
that in our state budget and we're
granted that position
the department then recruited and hired
for that position over the course of the
last year and once we had that position
filled began to began the process of
trying to figure out exactly what these
statutes require the department to do
and how the department was about to or
how the department and what the
department needed to implement these
statutes
simultaneously the department
um just through a transition
in Personnel at the department State
assessments became became part of my
division and we did the same thing for
RSA 193c which is the seed assessment
law so we have the assessment of State
accountability State assessment and
accountability now at the department and
we are now working to kind of organize
that and understand all of the state and
federal requirements that that division
or that Bureau has
um so through that work
we literally just mapped out basically
what we thought the law had said
um and you know tried to put together a
process of what we thought we needed to
do
now historically the state law was
changed in 2017 to replace the state
ibas or sorry State pbas the
performance-based accountability system
um
to align with the state every student
succeeds act plan so that was done maybe
I think 2017-18 it was right around the
same time that the state was actually
beginning to implement Essa for the
first time we hadn't actually run the
calculations or done any of the work and
whatnot relative to Essa so some of the
language that ended up in the state law
at that time
has either been changed or maybe too
repetitive of the federal law and
whatnot
um and then in 2000 I believe it was 19
or 20
um the legislature changed the state law
for requiring a school district to prove
that they're providing an adequate
education through both ibass and pbas
the input based accountability system
ibass and pbas a performance-based
accountability system so previously a
school district could prove that they
were providing an adequate education
through either so either the ibass or
the pbas and so that change was made
this change was made before the
department began this process of trying
to understand the current laws and
whatnot and actually it was funny
because we actually had somebody that
was kind of referring to one section of
the law and RSA 193h and they're saying
oh yeah well pbas requires this and the
school's only required to do a p-bas and
then he said well you have to actually
read RSA 193 E2 which then actually
refers back to both ibass and PBS so
there's already a few areas where the
law is very confusing
so through this process and US mapping
out the laws and and whatnot and kind of
what we need to do we said well why
don't we do a comprehensive rewrite of
these three sections of law to make sure
that they make sense and that they are
clear and give the department a path
forward to the work that we are required
to do so most of the changes you have in
front of you we are not trying to change
the current process the current system
and the current requirements on school
districts but what we're trying to do is
give us essentially the ability to
implement the law in a clear path
forward
and then knowing that
there are some changes that our actual
policy changes that members of the
committee might want to make in school
districts School Board School members
might want to make as well there's a
time for that presidentially in the
future after this bill but this bill is
really just to give us the authority to
do what we believe exists in current law
so
um given that I do believe does the
committee have the document from Gen 4
okay so
um we were sent that last night as well
I mean Nate and I went through it
um on a line by line basis there was an
actually great information in that
document now I can't imagine having to
put it together again but
um I think it's extremely helpful
um and so if this time if the committee
has time today we could talk through
that on the line by line basis and go
through it or we could do that in the
work session or I just don't I don't
know how you want to do I it's a 42-page
document so I would imagine it will take
um my personal feeling is that you
probably need a work session to uh to
work through this I think we're already
behind a little bit today and we would
be way behind uh if you went through it
all today representative Miler I think
in talking with the chairman Ladd
we have uh rescheduled the HB 272 to the
18th so there's a gap tomorrow
between our 11 31 and the 131 and I
think it's his intent tomorrow to have
at least an initial work session on this
particular Bill dealing dealing with the
work that Jen has done so that's that's
our plan initially and we may need to
have more time but this at least will
give us the first blush of looking at
this uh tomorrow okay
um I know I'm not available tomorrow at
that time and Nate I'm just going to
thank you
um
questions at the moment
yeah I will say you know
being on this committee for 11 years
every time somebody says well we just
had to rewrite it's uh it's just uh this
uh raises red flag for me initially on
initial blush on this to make sure it
make damn sure that it's not just a
rewrite but that and so that's that's
the perceptual screen that I've got When
anybody says that to me so this this
will obviously have to have a lot of
work before we actually act on it I
think that's fair and I think that even
going through the document that Jen
prepared um do we noticed for example
there was a definition that was missing
and so well we didn't intend on getting
rid of this definition
in our we went back and looked at our
notes because we have folders and
folders of notes that we were preparing
going through this and we had not
deleted that definition but it did go
away so that would be an area for us to
to fix that um but yes
let's try thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for being here
um the thing that actually made thank
you very much for the side-by-side
version amazing to do
um uh the thing that jumped out to me
and it's just because I focus on this
aspect is the part about rule making and
it changes from a shall to a May and
that's a big deal to me
um the the notes say the section's
identical in both versions but it's not
because it's a shell and the concurrent
section is relative to the assessment
and having rules around the assessment
the department does not currently have
assessment rules and so we don't
necessarily feel like they're necessary
we may want to do assessment we may want
to do rules on that going forward but as
of right now we have not had rules and
we we're implementing the program
without rules okay even though it's set
excuse me follow-up even though it said
in the current rules it says shall
adoptables they haven't been adopted we
don't have assessment rules okay thank
you
representative Cornell thank you Nate is
this the side by side we talked about on
Monday at the oversight committee so if
there's a I think there were a couple
things we talked about
um at the oversight committee on Monday
so there's another side by side for the
minimum standards work okay um that I I
have this morning now and I'll send that
out to the committee as well I was
getting so there are multiple side by
sides yeah that's the thing this doesn't
look like what we were talking about no
this is this is different from okay
great so I'm glad there's another side
by side thank you you're welcome
you're requesting more side by sides
um
um representative cascadden thank you um
just a comment I think that when we're
um next week when we have that break it
doesn't seem long enough for me and I
fear that we're going to get it oh
tomorrow okay because
um I fear that we're gonna get knee deep
into it and we're gonna have to cut it
short and I I'd like to suggest that we
have an exact session to begin the day
with that so that we're not
scrambling
just a suggestion thanks
yeah I I would guess there will be
multiple work sessions on this
yeah
um and I know chairman was going to be
working on a schedule for uh next week
um so you know we'll see about that
go ahead please thank you representative
uh just one question for you you're not
going to be changing the input based or
the performance base that's going to be
maintained that is correct we uh and
right now we would like to leave it
exactly the same we're just clarifying
that so the input based accountability
system is there it is specific to the
criteria for an adequate education I'm
sure that you remember that the input
based accountability system before was
very long we have actually internally
gone through and taken the things that
are not relevant to the criteria for an
adequate education out of the
performance space because there was
other information that was in that but
we do intend to really true up the
perform the performance space or sorry
the ibass to the intent of the law the
performance-based accountability system
is aligned with Essa and current law and
so the weird thing was not the weird
thing uh the thing that we did at the
department at the time was we did
regurgitate some of the federal law into
the state statute and we felt we could
take that out of the state law and refer
just back to the federal statute that
way if there were changes in one area or
the other and now they didn't match each
other so that's all we did but we still
intend the performance-based
accountability system to align with the
federal Essa plan which is that's in
current law and then the input-based
accountability system to be a survey
with narratives that aligns to the
criteria for an adequate education as
defined in RSA 193e
and remind me to follow up
remind me again school districts have to
do both or one or the other so it was in
2019 or 2020 somebody from the committee
actually representative lad might
remember because I think it was his bill
um it changed to both previously it had
been or but it was changed three or four
um maybe for the new committee members
could you just touch on Essa what
asset is oh sure um the every student
succeeds act as a federal act that
um has a variety of state or sorry a
variety of accountability requirements
that states are required to comply with
um so it has information around status
assessments and then performance in
certain subgroups so the state has a
state plan that has been approved by the
U.S Department of Education and we are
using that information to determine
schools as either CSI comprehensive
support assistant schools Improvement
schools and can you he's better with the
definitions sure yeah so so the state
Esso plan is a way for us to identify
High performing and low performing
schools using a variety of indicators so
we have three different designations for
schools CSI TSI and ATS csir
comprehensive support and Improvement
which means on a whole a school across
the board for their students tend to be
in the lower performing of schools in
the state TSI and atsi schools are based
more off of subgroups so you may have a
school that overall is doing well
academically but they may have one or
two subgroups of students that are
performing lower than their peers
oftentimes we see this with subgroups
such as low-income students or students
with IEPs or students with disabilities
and so there are different ways of
identifying schools but for the most
part we use the state assessment data to
do those identifications and that's all
yes representative Damon thank you Mr
chair
more than one question here the first
one is not meant humorously is there a
list of acronyms that the Department of
Education uses somewhere there so yes
and no I would say probably the closest
thing on our our website we have our I
platform system so all of our data is
through that I report I define i define
specifically as our data dictionary so
everything that we report on has a
definition in that data dictionary so if
you're looking at something that you
know some indicator or some piece of
data that's on our website it should
also be within that data dictionary and
you should be able to see where the data
comes from and what it means that's not
necessarily a list of acronyms but it's
probably the closest thing that we have
right now
maybe we'll have a bill about acronyms
next year I mean actually as a back to
this whole purpose we found a lot of
areas where there were terms that were
used that were not defined or there were
definitions that were used like the
actually terms that were defined but
then the terms were not used anywhere in
that section of law so we did try to
clean some of that up in this
um
simultaneously the department did put in
a bill to have a recodification of the
education laws and I believe that's
floating around someplace in finance as
far as the state budget is concerned but
it's that might be a an opportunity for
that
follow
um so when did
the federal government Implement Essa
2017 was when our student plan was
representative Lucas
so then once these schools are
identified and have their little acronym
attached to them what happens so there
is a in law right now there's a step of
it's actually do you have a bill in
front of you
um well let's talk about this yeah so
the bill in front of you on page
see
on page 11 that's where the technical
the correction and technical assistance
work goes into place
so that's once a school's been
identified and that's mirrors the
current existing state law there we
didn't propose any changes to this
section
see none
um thank you very much and um I'm sure
we'll be uh seeing quite a bit of you in
um and um uh Mr Green you can possibly
have time tomorrow if if we do have
uh was there anybody else who wanted to
uh testify on this
bill
see none we'll close the hearing on
Senate Bill 266 and move right into uh
okay
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
I'm Bruce Ford and I represent Senate
the Senate Bill 25
is a repeals the Department of Education
reporting requirement on payments made
in fiscal year to a chartered Public
School
and it's no longer needed and that's why
and again any questions Department of
thank you Senator uh questions for the
senator
seeing none uh representative Damon
excuse me thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Senator Ward was
this bill requested by Doe why didn't
was this bill requested by the
yes representative
the other day didn't didn't you pass a
similar bill in the Senate uh our house
bill coming up who passed the bill of
the Senate yes and but we we passed a
bill like this uh in the house and I
believe it was
it went through the Senate the other day
when I was there
you know a couple of times I have found
that identical bills have shown up both
in the house and the Senate
in one place I found one word was
changed that was that was the only
difference between them so it's double
thank you any further questions
I see none thank you very much Senator
um did we have any other we didn't have
did the committee members think that
there was any technical assistance
required from the Department on this
bill
this is the same exact Bill uh yes okay
thank you well then in in that case
we'll uh get ahead of schedule and uh
close the hearing on uh Senate bill 25.
um and
um
we'll take no action on that right now
um and so I guess we have our next bill
at one o'clock and we can uh recess
until that time
we have SB 136 scheduled to start eight
minutes ago or six minutes ago that's
prohibiting the employment or
volunteering of a revoked or suspended
educator
and looks like we have Ruth here
hello Grant
Bruce Bruce Ward is the senator
sponsoring this bill and
she sent the other side yes thank you uh
Mr chairman members of the committee uh
I am not Ruth Ward I am graph Aussie
Deputy Chief of Staff in the New
Hampshire Senate here on behalf
of Senator Ward the prime sponsor of
Senate bill 136. sb-136 would update the
statute governing the revoked and
suspended educator list RSA
18913a suspended Educators could be
hired in anticipation of when that
suspension was going to be lifted or if
an educator maintains a valid credential
in another endorsement area
aside from where their endorsement was
revoked or suspended it would also
ensure that Educators with revoked
credentials would not be hired as
Volunteers in the school notably this
bill would not prevent former Educators
from activities that are open to the
public in general such as attending a
basketball game or a high school
graduation it would not limit their
rights as a parent uh the Department of
Education is here to answer any
questions you may have about the
credential revocation process and the
changes that SB 136 would make Senator
thanks for your consideration and ask
for your support for Senate Bill 136.
thank you great
um I take it you probably are not
interested in uh questions at this point
I always
questions I can't promise answers okay I
would defer to the department if you
have anything for Senator Ward
specifically I can take notes and get an
answer back to you thank you any
questions for Mr bossy
see you none thank you very much and I
will mention that Diana Fenton is here
from the Department for any technical
assistance but next I'll call on Megan
Tuttle
thank you for the record my name is
Megan Tuttle I'm president of Nea New
Hampshire representing 17 000 Educators
across the state and I did come up with
Diane FN from the doe because we did
work on this together so
we're in full support of this
um
dogs and that's it living in harmony
I think the committee will appreciate
the fact that uh Megan and I are here
testifying jointly for the record Diana
Fenton with the Department of Education
uh I want to thank Megan
um and the Nea right before
um President's Day weekend the three-day
weekend I called her on a Friday morning
which is really mean and I said hey
Senate Bill 136. where are you guys at
with it and she said let me take a look
at it and I will get you my thoughts by
this afternoon and she did she sent me
an amendment um that the department was
amenable to that we can live with
um but we have worked really closely on
this bill together
um I think it's important to note that
the revoked and suspended educator list
we have an entire process set up to
ensure that Educators get the due
process that they are entitled to and
deserve but there are some offenses on
that list that are not Criminal
so the idea that an HR department can do
a Google Search and and find out the
history is not entirely accurate and the
anecdotal story I share is we had a
gentleman who
um wrote A A Love Song to a 13 year old
child and sent it to her
um and that's not illegal conduct it
should be but that's for another
committee to decide down the hall in
criminal justice
um and this superintendent did did
everything she was supposed to do and
worked with the department and we took
action on that gentleman's license so
that he would not go to another District
um and I'm not here to speak for that
superintendent but I can tell you that
and I will paraphrase she said I've
never seen anything like this before she
said he wrote a complete love song with
lyrics and a musical clip where he sang
it
um and yes that is exactly the right
reaction and those are the types of
behaviors that working together with Nea
we are stopping and we are stopping from
going from one District to another
district and the department can't do it
alone
we do it with with our partners at the
union and yes that's right I said
Partners at the union
and this is on video so everyone does
see it up here together
um but you know one of our concerns with
this when I originally came out was
stopping as um it was introduced a
parent who might be an educator from
going to something this is not to say
that they should be going on like the DC
trip or anything like that if they're on
one of these lists because obviously
they shouldn't this is more you know we
wanted to make sure that you know as a
parent if you're an educator but your
license is revoked or suspended you can
still go to graduation or to like they
said the basketball game Etc so the
language in here allows that in the
amendment and so we are in full support
of it
thank you
um representative miler
thank you Mr chair so could you
succinctly give us the intent
of this bill
which one of us whoever I mean for us
it's bad if you are on the vote or
suspended less that you are on there for
a reason and you're not you know if
you're on the revoked list you're not
going to be hired somewhere else because
if you're on the revoked list that's
usually pretty serious offense
and most likely you should not be around
children in the teaching capacity or
educator capacity
um the suspended list
until you're off suspension because it's
a lesser offense you know you should
still be allowed later when you're off
the list to get a job
um and I will just add to it the intent
of this is to ensure that
um all districts
understand the severity of that list
and take the time to review that list in
making their hiring decisions thank you
representative Cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um it says non-public schools
um could you explain what you mean by
non-public schools and and do we have
any control over non-public schools so
um
we wanted this to be applicable to the
private schools as well and if you look
at 189 13A in its entirety it does say
that a non-public school does not have
to follow the procedure set forth in the
statute
as it applies to criminal history checks
but if they do so they have to follow
the entire statutory provision they
can't pick and choose which Provisions
they take on so this would be saying
that if we have an educator who's
writing love songs so 13 year old childs
children and we don't want them in the
public school we don't want them in the
private school either
and we felt that that was appropriate
representative Tanner just thank you and
just as a follow-up because I had that
circled as well
um what about approved schools for
tuition
uh that uh when I see that non-public
school I understand about the private
school part but what about all these
approved schools for tuition purposes
my understanding and I can double check
my understanding is the approved schools
for tuition would fall within the 189
13A I think it is equally applicable but
I will double check on that and get back
to you thank you representative
cascadden
thank you representative uh thank you
for taking my question and I it's a
little twofold I'm looking at number one
and two in line six seven and eight
so if an educator has been suspended for
a violation
and they are dual certified
say English and special ed you can keep
that person on staff if they teach
special ed if they wrote a song in
English
I mean to the Inc
wait a minute so somebody's dual
certified yeah
and I'll use the example you gave of the
teacher wrote A Love Song to a student
or however you want to interpret that
and he was serving in a cat he or she
was serving in a capacity of an English
teacher sure
so if his English credentials are
suspended for that violation can that
District keep that teacher on if they
reassign them to special education
the short answer is no typically when
the department takes the action what
your what you are referring to are the
endorsements right right and it's not
unusual for an educator to have multiple
endorsements right
um special ed endorsement social studies
endorsement principal endorsement
doesn't mean that they're serving in
that capacity employment wise but they
have these endorsements
typically with very rare exception
when the department takes action on an
Educator's teaching credential and
please know the department does not do
that lightly those are very serious
offenses it is a child safety issue and
the department does not split the
endorsements we would not say well you
taught this class and you wrote a love
song to a child in this class so we're
going to take that endorsement
historically we have learned that that
doesn't work
that is just a slap on the wrist and
it's ineffective and so if we take that
kind of action
um again we don't take it lightly we
take it for all endorsement areas there
have been some exceptions to that
um but that is not the that is not the
norm
follow-up please
um so the second scenario is
Educators who have their credentials
suspended
there's a time limit on that I thought
once they were revoked they were revoked
forever
so a revocation is a permanent
rescission okay a revocation is uh
reserved permanent
for individuals Educators who are having
a sexual relationship with a child right
we've had examples of that there are
other
um
situations where a suspension is the
appropriate course and we work with the
Union to put in parameters they might be
classes they might be ethics courses to
get that person back into the classroom
and those are for set periods of time
that we agree ahead of time with the
Union what that is so suspension would
have an end date yes and I'm sorry can I
just finish it up please
um so a teacher who has a suspended
certification and then the certification
lapse and they get their recertification
again and go to another District now
when they go to another District they
have to have criminal background check
will that history show up for that
district and then is it up to that
District to decide whether they hire
them or not
to follow me I'm just trying to see so
uh well a suspension is different than a
um the actions that are taken on the
revoked and suspended educator list
do not that list is separate and
distinct from a criminal history okay
that's where I was going with that
because I mean for me it's like well
they've been if they've had credential
suspended or revoked I don't really I
um so we that is a completely separate
concept from the criminal history
records check okay if someone has
um
whatever action on the license is not
reflective on the criminal history
records check
um the department does send out the
revoked and suspended educator list on a
regular basis and it is uh available and
then when the person is no longer
suspended we remove that person from the
list right some superintendents have
expressed exactly what you just
expressed which is I I don't want to
have this so some superintendents as
part of their practice hold on to those
older lists that's perfectly within
their purview from the Department's
practice position and the Nei
we remove that individual once they are
no longer suspended
yeah thank you we just want to make sure
that once they are no longer suspended
their name is off the list there have
been cases mistakes in the past where
their name has been left on and that's
partly why we want to make sure that
their name is off like like Dana said
it's an employment issue if the
superintendent wants to you know hire
someone who's been on the list or not
for suspension right so up to the
district's discretion good thank you
are there any other questions represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um obviously I'm a bit newer um and I
don't have a full scope of understanding
of the Department's authorities when it
comes to this sort of thing you gave an
excellent example of somebody who should
obviously never be anywhere near
children but I'm also curious what are
the sort of totality of um Authority the
department has when it comes to
suspensions and what might the lightest
infractions be for which somebody might
be suspended
um it's actually a lot of fun to testify
with the Union I wish we we had more of
these bills um well it's interesting too
he's asking a prosecutor I know right
well that was my old job
so because the Department issues the
credential or the license to teach
the department is the exclusive agency
that can take action on that document so
our Authority if you will only applies
to certified Educators so if you are a
non-certified para educator
we don't have any authority of that
um that is separate and apart from
employment
and what we have found historically and
again if we use that example uh that
individual who wrote that love song
would would have been and was dealt with
employment wise he um offered his
resignation it was accepted
and the superintendent said quite
succinctly I'm done
my kids are safe he's out of my district
I'm moving on with my life and I asked
her one point question which was
what about all the other kids
where is he going to go
what about the children in the next
District I myself am a product of New
Hampshire public education and my
child's in New Hampshire public
education please don't send him to my
district what about all the other
children and that's the Department's
purview
we have broader jurisdiction we are
Statewide whereas the superintendent
only has Authority in that District
representative can speak to that uh more
thoroughly than I can however our scope
is much narrower and I want to emphasize
that so what does that mean there might
be a lot of employment infractions that
go to the superintendent dress code
not having your curriculum in order not
having good classroom management skills
none of that falls within our radar none
of it
if it concerns the interactions and
safety of a child however
then the department steps in so broader
go ahead just real quick and that was an
excellent response but it brought up one
quick idea which is so if it concerns
the well-being and sort of What Not of a
child would that extend to
um things like the social emotional
well-being or is this more of a physical
threat danger type of a thing threat
danger thank you yes further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you it's
delightful having both of you together
I need a little further understanding on
the question of multiple endorsements
sure
so from your response to representative
cascadden's query
I guess I don't really understand why
lines eight to ten are in there because
I thought I heard you say
that
if your license was suspended or revoked
it sounded like you said the op to me
like you said the opposite of what it
says here
so
help me out sure no thank you for the
question
generally speaking
if the department takes action on a
license that includes all endorsement
areas
there have been
um two circumstances two instances in
which we have said we are going to look
at the credential and the endorsements
and allow someone to keep a certain
endorsement area
I'll give you an example and I want to
just emphasize it's very very rare but
Megan was Savvy enough to say let's
recognize it even though it might be an
anomaly it has happened and I'm sure
she's probably thinking in the same
cases that I am that's why we put that
in here
so we have the example I will share with
you is we had an educator who
um had an endorsement in Special Ed
special ed Administration I believe
and
it was in special ed administration were
inappropriate in that
um
it was a misuse of her authority of
placing children and it was costing the
district
thousands if not millions of dollars in
violation of regulations
and this was systemic and it occurred on
a regular basis
however
she was not having an inappropriate
relationship with a child
and by all accounts in her other
endorsement area
was an appropriate educator and an
effective educator
a good educator
and that was a very rare occurrence in
which we said okay this endorsement area
where she has a role of an as an
administrator
that's being used inappropriately
she admitted as such
and voluntarily gave that endorsement up
but we allowed her to stay in the
classroom as an educator where she was
productive and positive and and by all
accounts
doing good in our schools that doesn't
happen every day
but the department can and does use that
discretion
from time to time
um were you thinking of that case okay
that's helpful thank you but again very
does the department share any of this
information with our neighboring states
Maine Vermont
Massachusetts in terms of some of the
scenarios she was just mentioned so you
lose your ticket in this date
what happens when they go just a mile
away on the other side of the line sure
it's a great question and there's and
there's agreement between the states
that's when these tickets go back and
forth you know you're certified here we
accept that certification in our state
sure a lot of States Grant reciprocity
yeah
um so there is a national group
um the group is NASDAQ National Stock
Market not the stock market I spent the
six first six months in my job thinking
it was the stock market it is a national
group and it is designed and created to
address the exact issue that
representative Ladd just asked about and
so you have to be a member of NASDAQ the
state of New Hampshire is a member of
NASDAQ what does that mean that means
when someone comes
[Music]
to New Hampshire from another state
to get certified as an educator New
Hampshire Department of Education will
run that individual's name and social
security number through NASDAQ
to see if they have had action taken on
their teaching license in another state
that's all 50 states
and when we take action we will enter
that individual into NASDAQ
um people will enter when they're able
to if they're members but it is pretty
uh all-inclusive and it we have had some
success with that so we we have gotten
calls from other states saying someone
has moved here they want a teaching
license we see you've taken action what
were the grounds for that
what's the story behind that I will also
just share with you it's a tad off topic
but this um legislative body helped to
pass it when the Department issues a
license to teach they also run a Check
of the individual's name into the New
Hampshire dcyf essential registry that
is a tool that this legislative body
helped to pass so we are now doing that
and we are working towards doing that in
our sister States namely Massachusetts
as well that's a tool that a school
district does not have
so the state agency is taking the lead
on that to say when we license we have
we will assure you that that person is
not in those databases
and we're very proud of that initiative
yeah thank you uh further questions
okay that's that's nice so with that
we're going to close this hearing
and move on to the next scheduled
hearing which we have today that's
scheduled for 1 30 in a couple minutes
we'll start that up
relative to New Hampshire Workforce
foreign
okay can you please go ahead and protect
the bill
uh thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Vice
chairman I'm Senator David Waters
District Four to introduce Senate Bill
152 relative natural Workforce training
programs and uh we're all trying to do
something about Workforce and uh here's
a bill that can address a couple of
areas you get you're going to get two
Workforce uh developments for the price
of one in this bill
um I want to thank very much Jeff beard
of the Department of Education who heads
up the CTE programs and particularly
want to thank commissioner Ada blue for
all of his uh work on figuring out how
to make this both parts of this build
um work so the first part of the bill is
going to establish a pathway for marine
trades at one of our ctes and um
this uh arose initially out of
um the Marine trades and marinas up in
the Lakes Region who are facing a real
critical shortage of workers and are
really concerned about how to get a
pathway for uh training in that area and
you know part of it is that a lot of the
um Automotive programs which you might
think you know engines or engines but a
lot of the students in the automotive
programs are really want to do cars so
the idea is that if we establish a
pathway so that they could have a
sequence of courses in this area
internships other opportunities for
students to get out into the marinas
that that would be a good way to go
there's a considerable demand for these
uh workers that's the workforce is aging
out Marine trades is generally a growth
industry whether it's up along the lakes
or along the coast and it empowers the
Department of Education and specifically
commissioner Ada blue and director of
Career and Technical education to
establish the pathway I didn't specify
a particular Center I think it's likely
to start up in the in the Lakes Region
there's also good cooperation between
the CTE up there and um the Community
College because I do think that
eventually there'll probably be an
interest in doing one of these on a Sea
Coast as well for marine trades
um and uh there are existing facilities
at these centers that could handle the
program so we're not looking for
um any kind of appropriation outside of
you know if there are some funds needed
there's a grant program that the
commissioner has that any Center can
apply to for any any reason
um I think you're going to see that a
lot of local Business Leaders uh from
the marinas and elsewhere really want to
want this track
um to work and I will also notice
because of actions taken in the
legislature that there is a tax credit
program for
um businesses that want to contribute
equipment to the ctes or staff time for
training they can get a tax credit by
working with the CTE so I suspect
that'll be a nice incentive uh as well
um the other part of the bill deals the
offshore wind
industry and I'll just tell you you know
explain why we need to do this right
right now and how I put the bill
together I'm chair of our New Hampshire
offshore wind
uh important development commission uh
Governor sununu three years three four
years ago now um was the governor who
called for the creation of Gulf of Maine
task force for offshore wind industry
composed of Massachusetts New Hampshire
and uh Massachusetts
um this is a huge industry uh it is uh
enormous financial support from the
industry and from other sources if you
look around it's certainly developing
very quickly along Southern New England
coast and up and down the east coast and
now off of California and Oregon as well
um the plans are for about 3.2 gigawatts
in the initial energy development field
out in the Gulf of Maine Gulf of Maine
has been called the Saudi Arabia of wind
because we have extraordinary wind
resources out there that would power
that's about 3C Brooks so we're talking
about you know one and a half million
homes potentially powered by it in a lot
of Industry as well about a three three
to five billion dollar construction
phase about a 12 to 16 billion dollar
supply chain so the industry is chopping
at the bit to get a Workforce and to get
these Investments made for New Hampshire
the Gulf of Maine auctions the they've
just established the lease auction areas
the final map was released just a few
weeks ago and now there are five
developers are going to bid into those
auctions on third quarter of next year
which in terms of the industry is really
tomorrow so they're going to start
looking at ports they can use and how
they're going to get a Workforce for it
so that's the impetus behind the bill is
that we need to get ready on doing some
uh Workforce
um on development now you'll see what
the bill does then it establishes a fund
so they can we receive non-state
Appropriations and come into this fund I
will say at this point that the industry
has already put tens of millions of
dollars into similar training facilities
in Southern New England and up and down
the east coast and elsewhere
the IRA act has many billions of dollars
of funding for Workforce Development and
also apparently there's a new
requirement for offshore wind auctions
of five percent of the auctions being
dedicated towards Workforce Development
the most recent auctions were held were
for floating offshore wind which is what
we're going to have out off the coast of
California
and the average price for the three
loose areas just about the same size
what we're going to do is about 160 570
million dollars so you can do the math
and five percent of that we're going to
have some real money coming in for for
Workforce training so we got to set up a
fund um so we can receive those funds
and then a process whereby the
commission of education and the Bia and
the industry
um Department of Employment Security
community college system University
system
um other entities such as unions the
industries that are going to emerge in
New Hampshire manufacturing around this
industry they're going to be
Consolidated together and say what do we
need uh in this in this and then there's
going to be you'll see on page two
we've set up this um Training Center
committee which I think has all the
people on or who wanted to be on it and
are appropriate to
be on it um so that this group uh can
make some determinations
um about recommendations on Workforce
training you know what what trade should
be focused on
um particularly uh to pick a site there
are several possibilities
the feeling is after conversation with
Great Bay Community College and others
that this ought to be at the Port so
Gina Marconi or the Port Authority is
interested we could have facility there
Granite Shore power which some of you
may know in Newington has a lot of land
they have some plans to develop some
very large facilities there warehouses
and other training facilities so it
could be there or one of the empty
buildings over at the mall are all
Targets for of Interest around around
that
um and uh so potentially um you know
money from the industry and elsewhere to
figure out where to where to do this
what what is appropriate to build and uh
and who to train there
um so you see the bill is crafted not to
require State appropriation at this uh
time we're going to get reports both on
the activities of that group and on any
fund activities as well you see that on
page three pretty much weight language
for the way we handle uh handle funds
um I just didn't in conclusion will say
I think this is an extraordinary
opportunity for New Hampshire good high
paying jobs extraordinary amounts of
energy that's going to likely to come in
at a much cheaper supply of energies
than any other source that uh that we
have available to us and um I don't want
all those jobs going to Massachusetts in
May and I want them right here in New
of course
thank you thank you for being here and
bringing this forward
if this bill were signed into law what
would be the timeline for training
Educators acquiring a location getting
all the resources and really getting
this program off the ground
that's your question
um
I mean Marine trades program I think
we're going right away the one up in the
Lakes Region on the other other part
here
um
I I'm going to speculate just a little
bit okay so if the auctions are coming
up
third quarter next year
I think we're gonna we're already seeing
the industry looking around New
Hampshire there's an office that's been
opened up in Boston by uh
um one of the biggest
um energy developers in this area and
there's actually three of them already
have offices there and they're looking
around we had an offshore wind Summit
um last spring I should mention uh
assistant Des commissioner Mark Sanborn
who's the governor's Point person
offshore wind he's down at offshore wind
industry meetings down in New Jersey
right now otherwise I think he would
have been would have been here
um and I right now we're trying through
our office of offshore wind in business
economic Affairs trying to talk to folks
so I I think it's very possible next
year we'll start to see some real action
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um does this have a connection or a link
to Community College or is this industry
ready to hire high school graduates that
have gone through this Marines trades
program
um all of the above
um Great Bay Community College and a
Consortium of ctes are going to be very
important here
um the sea Grant operation at uh
University of New Hampshire is empowered
by federal statute to work on Workforce
Development so they're they're at the
table here as well and um the kind of
jobs I mean it's everything from from
Health Care uh to manufacturing to
um you know divers if you have a welding
and if you if you have welding out of
CTE and a diver certificate you started
like 150 000 a year plus benefits so um
and then plus everything everybody else
seeing my thing on electrical servicing
uh you know the servicing the industry
getting workers out there so I think
there's going to be opportunities for
all levels but the hot you know I want
us to get the good paying jobs and so
the student who goes through CTE if they
are are welding electrical manufacturing
kinds of programs they're going to be
well positioned to get additional
training specific to the industry and
then of course the seat the Community
College programs that we have existing
in in the area is going to be hireable
here so
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
so generally with CTE programs I'm I'm
pretty excited about the idea of them I
like the idea that our students are
getting trained to do jobs but I also
think because the you know obviously the
New Hampshire taxpayer is footing the
bill the overall they should overall see
a benefit from it so I have a little bit
of a concern and I'm hoping you can
speak to that on the wind energy portion
of it because I I know when I'm looking
at some of the stats wind energy being
per unit of energy produced one of the
highest subsidized types of energy right
now is this not effectively another
subsidy for wind energy
oh I mean it's it's an interesting
argument you know in that um clearly
right now
there is a lot of funding support for
this industry in the ira
and in other incentives being offered I
think the kind of recognition is that as
the price
uh and the supply chain you know as
we're starting to build these
that the necessity of those kinds of
support for industry and for renewable
energy standards
um may change I will say right now
though for New Hampshire's perspective
that we are not a state that is
providing direct subsidies here right
because other other you know
Massachusetts another removal forefoose
standards and we have not decided to do
that so I think our taxpayers actually
stand to really benefit greatly uh from
Mr chairman thank you for answering all
these questions
um just to follow up on what the
representative is saying
the offshore wind industry is big but
it's not just in New Hampshire so
is the committee going to look at how to
keep keep our Workforce here I mean or
incentives to to just use the training
where they got it yes thanks for your
question representative I mean it's a
great question I think a lot of the jobs
are likely to be local and you know the
construction phase those folks the
construction phase will will be done and
oftentimes it's like with our um you
know Local ibw 104 workers the people
who do the high wires that's a mobile
Workforce and some people New Hampshire
already now training down in New Bedford
and then they come up they'll come up
here and do this work so you know
there's some Mobility they go over the
gonna go where the jobs are
um but I what I fear the most is that if
we don't train a Workforce they're going
to bring in European workers
and uh because the industry is far more
advanced in in Europe than it is here so
um
you know I I think we have an
opportunity here I think there's going
to be a lot of ongoing jobs uh there'll
probably be a second phase to the Gulf
of Maine 10 years or so from now so um
you know it's a Marketplace though isn't
it you know it's the industry is the
industry and uh I just want to make sure
the New Hampshire says we're open for
business and we want some good jobs here
and um the business the industry will
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
another one of my questions
some other programs such as the Health
Sciences students can graduate with like
an l a certificate or EMT license would
there be a certificate at the end of
this program to give students a
competitive advantage in entering the
workforce is there something in this
field like that
thanks for the question I would hope so
you know health care workers um even you
know um catering you know there's all
kinds of jobs here but the health the
health health and safety kind of um jobs
are very important to the industry and
you know I would think you work for this
you've got a great credential you maybe
you want to go on to another
another project like this or maybe
you're going to work for one of the
hospitals or for another for another
business
um
and I just think it's I think these are
great opportunities and uh we gotta we
got to do a Workforce uh uh trying to
increase the workforce and Healthcare
here too don't we yes
Mr chair thank you Senator Waters
just wondering currently where these
opportunities don't exist in New
Hampshire
where do people get this training if
this weren't to happen where are people
going
well education part is actually the
question in the industry
um you know Massachusetts and connecting
around do their laws a little bit
different and the nicer to Coalition
which is New York New Jersey you know
all the places where offshore industry
developing I'll do a little bit
different about how their training
worker in education and and what kinds
of money and incentives
um because of the way they did some of
their contract done in Massachusetts I
think is like 40 million is in for
Workforce training
um at Mass Maritime
and in New Bedford
um if you go to the port of Portsmouth
uh Porter
um
Providence you'll see Workforce training
centers there that are that are run by
the industry and by the unions so
there's a lot of different models there
and as I said some of our workers are
going down there to get training now
um but the demand is going to be here
too now I the model I put together here
is a New Hampshire model
we have to get everybody at the table
the Bia
the the commissioner education Community
College is the University get the unions
in there because all their you know
they're training
begins to train a lot of folks and why
have duplicate efforts let's see if we
can get them the ctes get everybody
together and figure out how we're going
to train our workers best so we're going
to have our own model and the idea is
that we're going to get the money in
from the feds and from the industry and
they're they're you know once the
auctions happen next
year that's when I think we'll start to
thank you thank you I don't know
understand enough about the the
windforce one I don't understand what
the auctions are oh excuse me
so um the Bureau of energy ocean
management or Bureau of ocean Energy
Management volume as we call it
um is the lead agency from the federal
government for offshore wind development
because these are you know they're these
are going to be out in federal waters
like 40 40 50 miles out
um we're going to ensure the power so we
have state some State authority over it
as well so what they do is they set up a
task force process where there's a gulf
of Maine task force and that has dozens
of people on it from the three states
and the government agencies and so forth
and so the process is not only
developing the auction leases defining
what area out in the Gulf of Maine is
suitable environmentally for the
Fisheries for Homeland Security for the
Navy the Coast Guard Transit Lanes I
mean you name it it's complicated bottom
out there so they Define those areas
that are would be available
and then they have lease auctions where
you bid
to have the right to develop a certain
part of that real estate the most recent
auctions down in New York went out for
3.2 billion dollars
um that was a little high I think
they're good and they're going to have
maybe a little trouble
um but doing that you know for that that
price is just the entry level but uh set
out out in California it's quite similar
to us 160 570 million uh per loose area
so the auction will be held would be an
open auction people will bid and they'll
select the winners and and the bids will
will have all you know have got the
environmental the workforce the
relationship with the states outlined in
the the bid and then they'll go they'll
be awarded a bid and then that that
starts to several your process of um of
environmental review
um work about how you're going to
onshore the power I mean you name it so
following up on representative Cornell
so yeah how long do the leases last once
I'm trying to remember it was 20 years
or 30 years
something like that okay yeah
which is kind of the lifespan of the
equipment now they they can always
replace them but um you know the the
it's it's that period
hmm
my question is it's just pretty concern
that I do have regarding
all the equipments are in your dark
enough is that offshore
it's not like they have an Ellenberg a
lot of champagne or Bangor New York
I can't but it looks like he went
through a poverty-stricken area with the
power of the turbines are there people
thanks thanks for the question this is
offshore wind
industry entirely offshore wind we're
talking as I said you know 40 50 miles
out
[Music]
yeah and other trade and other trades
too you notice that um that training
center is not delimited in terms of what
can be done there so if there's the
opportunity to train people and that
they will be able to work in this
industry or go off and work in a similar
industry that might be on land or you
know might be cabling
thank you thank you Senator
um I've read several articles about
um
uh I guess it's probably in California
where they've had a number of mass
fishing and dying and there's some spec
excuse me speculation that the testing
that's being done for the sighting of
offshore wind
um is the cause of some of um those um
uh problems uh have in your discussions
with um others around the area
um have you heard of any discussion
along those lines well that's your
question and um you know we're getting a
little off the bill but let me say it
because I am chair of the commission and
we have discussed these things and I
would say thanks to um assistant
commissioner Mark Sanborn we have forged
a partnership with our fishermen in the
state which is unlike any other state
um to listen to them and make sure that
they're involved and all their concerns
are are being addressed we also and I
just not entirely aside we passed the
bill last year
which declared consistency which is a
small part of federal government you
know we have state waters up to three
miles Federal's out of 200. if we take
advantage of that federal statute we can
declare interests out to 200 miles when
it comes to economic and environmental
interests so we can protect our our
fishermen out there now what you're
referring to is some concern about whale
death off of New Jersey
um there has been if there's been some
scientific study that has done shown two
things that those whales were most
likely killed by strikes from increased
um traffic for container ships
and then secondly the kinds of concerns
about Sonic effects
are not done by the offshore wind
industry they don't use that kind of
that kind of so uh sonar uh that is the
Navy
that's doing that out in deeper waters
and
um particularly with our our areas we're
not going to be driving piles into the
bottom because these are floating
and um so and the mapping is being done
in a different way so I I know that was
out there I read all the Articles and
then I've also read the article saying
uh actually probably not related to
Offshore wind but you know this is why
we do research always has to continue
and
um you know we're I think we're dealing
with that very well in other areas this
is about Workforce Development and um
you can connect later if you'd like
uh I've got James Anderson
well good afternoon chairman Ladd
committee members
I am president and CEO of granite Shore
power testifying in support of Senate
bill 152.
granted Shore power is a wholesale
electric generator providing over one
gigawatt of seasonal and peaking
electric generation from its 11 fuel
diverse generating stations located
throughout New Hampshire
Grand Shore power has operated these
facilities since its acquisition of the
assets from Public Service Company of
New Hampshire in 2018
following the state mandated divestiture
from our earliest days gsp's message has
been consistent and clear
Granite sure power can be dependent on
whether on our coldest nights or hottest
days and we strongly support a
transition to the next generation of
energy resources in New Hampshire
we encourage a constructive dialogue
about how best to achieve our shared
decarbonization goals and advancing a
renewable and reliable energy
infrastructure for the New England
region
offshore wind and other renewable
generation are rapidly becoming a
realistic opportunity as policy and
resources are better aligned
we know there is approximately 35
gigawatts of offshore wind projects
either announced or in development
spanning from North Carolina to Maine
we are encouraged by the prospects of
projects located in the Gulf of Maine
once the U.S department of Interiors
Bureau of ocean and energy management
completes its leasing process
the offshore wind and other renewable
generation sectors require a
well-trained professional Workforce if
New Hampshire is going to benefit from
energy transition and renewable energy
opportunities not only decarbonization
efforts but also the economic growth it
is imperative that the state encourage
Workforce training and support
investment in a Workforce Training
Center convenient to the port facilities
in Portsmouth
New Hampshire is well suited to take
advantage of its highly qualified trade
professionals and educational
institutions to compete for the
businesses that will support projects
necessary to transition the region to
the next generation of energy resources
and Drive New Hampshire Commerce
Granite Shore power has a strong
relationship with the IBEW and employs
many of its professionals who are
electricians mechanics operators and
instrument and control technicians
we commend the sponsor and co-sponsor
for putting SB 152 forward and we
strongly support it
this bill will help New Hampshire lead
the way enabling energy and
infrastructure projects that are truly
transformative
moreover establishing a Workforce
Training Center committee that actively
engages the private sector and will
recommend sound policies is the right
thing to do
that committee will consider training
facilities and partners that will enable
critical Workforce Development and
create long-term employment
opportunities in close proximity to
these projects
it is critical that this work begin now
so we are not disadvantaged by other
states taking the lead New Hampshire
should lead in this area and this bill
will help do just that
thank you for the opportunity to share
My Views and I'll be happy to take any
questions
in the CTE programs we have now
in another area of inviting business to
help us out we have the New Hampshire
Automobile Dealers Association
bringing Toyota forward GM Etc standards
and personnel and dollars to help us
with CPE is your area of the business
willing to do the same
we are I mean I'm here advocating for
the IBEW members that I employ and their
professional trades that they represent
I believe those are critical jobs to New
Hampshire and to our country frankly and
I think there's tremendous growth
opportunity in the renewable sector not
just the offshore wind projects but also
other renewable projects and I think New
Hampshire needs to be a leader in
training those professionals to to lead
any other questions
uh good afternoon members of committee
uh chairman lad nice to see you uh
Associated builders and contractors we
will present uh about 270 employers here
in New Hampshire that are primarily uh
commercial industrial and heavy
construction contractors throughout the
state and uh for me more of I thought
I'd be here just as sort of a resource
let you all know if you have questions
about how apprenticeship things like
that function just in general we feel
that the bill makes some good strides we
are supportive of the bill because we
feel like offshore wind development is
something that's long overdue here in
the region
um just generally speaking the structure
of the bill seems to work pretty well
for it it is uh got a good
representation across the board from
some of the different constituencies
that will be affected um it doesn't
necessarily have specifically a
contractor representative on the
commission but we fill within the
current structure we'd be able to work
with uh the commission to develop a good
training program the ABC is one that is
actually helped create apprenticeship
programs across the country and right
here in New Hampshire as well we help a
lot of contractors to develop their
Workforce which is important for us
because we feel bills like this will
help address some of the shortages we
have in the workforce issues that we're
facing to give an example the average
age of a craft worker in the states
about 55 years young
and uh you know it we talk about a
little bit but it's it's becoming an
issue where today we don't have enough
people coming in through the trades uh
for for merit that is open shop or Union
and we feel at the end of the day that
the more we can do to help promote some
of those trainings through the CTE
centers and helping the pipeline in
through employers that have their own
independent apprenticeship programs as
well it certainly be welcome so as this
moves forward we encourage the support
of the bill and we hope to be a partner
to help develop what the bill sets
forward to do so with that have you take
any questions if anyone has any um
otherwise thank you for letting me speak
very much are there any questions
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
my name is Rob Warner I'm the state
director here in New Hampshire for the
leak of conservation voters
I also and the New Hampshire lead for a
coalition throughout the region called
New England for offshore wind
so I want to Echo a lot of what other
speakers have said in terms of the
opportunity
but I think that
this opportunity is going to create
tremendous
situations for many workers across the
region not only New Hampshire
to create very well-paying jobs
and to make sure that we are taking
advantage of this industry as I've been
stated previously
there are billions of dollars that are
going to be invested and are already
being invested this industry is well
underway throughout the east coast and
in Massachusetts for example The
Vineyard wind project is already laying
cable to be connected to Barnstable so
there are active projects going on right
now
our group of League conservation voters
and New England Frost our wind feels
very strongly that New Hampshire must
position itself to take best advantage
of this opportunity it means a lot of
economic development for our communities
it means Economic Opportunity for our
workers and it is a very long-term
proposition in terms of the Investments
that are going to be made so are you
talking about welders electricians are
you talking about
administrators talking about project
managers it's really a wide range of
opportunity and jobs that will be
created throughout the region and and in
this state because of the Investments
that are being made and will be made so
we will feel very strongly that this is
a investment
in Education and Training that is
essential for New Hampshire and the
future of our people and grew up
providing opportunity for our citizens
to better themselves and to better the
world actually
so thank you very much I have to take
any questions thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you
um I'd like to invite Jody grimbleless
there we go can you thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
um for the record my name is Jody
grimbulis I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Marine trades association with
me I have Jeremiah Burke general manager
of Goodhue Boat Company in Wolfeboro
Ossipee in the Sunapee region who is
also the vice president of the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association
we're here in support of Senate bill
152. I did submit testimony through
email but I have copies here as well if
anybody needs one I'll start with a
general statement and I'm going to turn
it over to the expert to uh to continue
any questions
so for the record we support this spill
wholeheartedly we're specifically
speaking to section one of the bill
which creates the Marine trades pathway
so it's uh page one lines one through
six we're going to focus our testimony
just really right there because it's
about the Marine trades
um we would have had more marinas here
today to support and show the commitment
of the industry toward this program but
today actually is the annual education
day fundamental so I have a picture of
about 70 Marina operators owners and
employees that have their thumbs up to
show you how supportive they are of this
bill I apologize that they couldn't be
here today
um recreational boating is about a one
two one point two billion dollar annual
economic impact in New Hampshire and
those are 2018 numbers as many of you
might know during the pandemic a lot of
people turn to the water to get out and
get out with their families so we're
expecting the 2023 numbers to come in
probably higher than that we have a lot
of New Hampshire marine-based businesses
that belong to the association
both in the Seacoast as well as in The
Lakes Region and there are lakes all
around our state so we're finding a
challenge with Workforce we're trying to
try to um work together and we're very
appreciative of sponsor Senator Waters
and representative Cordelia and all the
other sponsors who have seen this as a
need in our community so I will turn it
to Jeremiah who is the Oxford
thank you uh thanks for for hearing us
today
um I grew up in in The Lakes Region and
uh love what New Hampshire has to offer
and boating is one of those things that
brings families together it brings
people together and uh is is one of the
things that attracts a lot of tourists
to our area in The Lakes Region when I
became general manager of Goodhue
um
uh looking towards Workforce and needing
to to sustain our growing business
there weren't really places to go to
find uh development so I started
reaching out to Lakes Region Technology
Center right there in Wolfeboro for in
Partnerships with them uh invited field
trips to come out go to their career
days we're seeing students now with good
few t-shirts and sweatshirts that didn't
even work at Goodhue wearing these these
apparel and creating a buzz around
marinas and the industry and a lot of
times these students don't even realize
that there are careers in Marina
specifically there's currently not a
program at the Lakes Region Technology
Center for marine
as I going through the search trying to
find where do we attract people and and
just you know know workers no other
program that I could find in New
Hampshire
at the CT level
existed that I know of
there is at the community college a
program which is a phenomenal program
and we we actually use that program to
train technicians and continue their
education and send them to school there
but I had to actually go to Maine to
find a CTE program
at that level
had an Enlightenment there that the
actual curriculum exists already for
this type of program American boating
and Yacht council is a very well-known
accreditation and program within the
marina industry they have the textbooks
they have workbooks they have all of the
curriculum necessary to plug in and play
into our schools here in New Hampshire
um so certainly as far as timing to kind
of answer your question on if it's the
CTE programs in timing I feel that when
working with Lakes Region Technology
Center this could happen really quickly
the curriculums there the the program
the the principal and the school is
willing and our Partnerships with the
Marine trades Association we're ready to
help facilitate how we can
um which will also feed that Community
College level as well so I'm very
excited I started on this road probably
three or four years ago I feel like Cove
had kind of derailed it a little bit but
excited just to see it back moving
forward now if we can take any questions
if if you have any
are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing thank you very much have a
I don't have any other cards up here for
this bill
um is anybody else out there
you said Cornell wants director
do you want to talk
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um I'll just open it up to uh two
questions I'm happy to answer any 10
questions anyone may have you better
thank you how soon do you think the
program could be up and running in
whichever location is best for for this
program but it would be very quick the
the way this would work is rather than
bringing a separate and distinct Marine
trades program we would treat it as a
pathway uh course or a Capstone within
an existing program there's a number of
programs that would be good fits uh so
if we're thinking about Hull repair for
example auto body is going to be a
natural fit where students that are
going through the auto body program
would then take a Capstone or additional
course that would then be specific to
hole repair
we would develop a set of competencies
that are unique to Marine trades
the things that a student would need to
know and be able to do in order to work
in a field that's related to something
we've already studied so I think some of
the natural fits would be auto body
repair technology Auto Body rather Auto
technology for the the engine part of it
diesel equipment but also there's some
other interesting opportunity is an area
of welding welding soldering and I think
those can be brought on very quickly the
there's a question earlier about
industry recognized credentials and that
dual certification of welding
certification and Diving would be a
great fit a number of our CTE programs
have Municipal pools that are right
close by Dover and Portsmouth will
spring to mind so young person could be
scuba certified and do a welding program
at the same CT Center come out with two
certifications
you're welcome
representative cascadden thank you thank
you for coming to the table you made me
think of a question I think this is a
great Bell I love to see expansion of
ctes and pathways
but from an administrative perspective
does that mean the school district needs
to seek out in an additional
Personnel to be able to from the field
to be able to provide that program or
would it be integrated within whatever
programs the school has already
thank you for the question
representative cascaden um the answer is
is the latter the the existing program
would have these additional competencies
every CTE program has a program advisory
committee one of our requirements is
work-based learning so taking part in
either authentic or simulated uh work
that includes sustained interaction with
industry professionals so some of that
direct instruction that's specific to
the Marine trades could be provided by
the supervision could be provided by
that program advisory committee member
coming in and doing their time taking
advantage of the tax credit
and the the district would not need to
hire any additional Advanced endorse
endorsements of certified personnel
you're welcome
I'm on track with you instead of
increasing that budget by 2 million to
11 million per year of the biennium
we're going to have to increase it to
it's going to grow
yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question how much capacity do the
existing programs have for instance when
you referenced the overlap with the auto
body can you accommodate a lot more
students that's a great question and I
think the way that it will work out is
it probably won't be an influx of
additional students to begin with I
think once these these path leads are
established that may attract more
students that have an interest I think
the way it will work in the present time
is already we've we've opened up um
thank you to to this body
um CTE is now open to students that have
completed one year of high school so
whereas in the past CT was often junior
year senior year now it's sophomore year
junior year senior year so there's an
opportunity that opens up for a young
person who goes into a program in the
sophomore year to go through say let's
say for the sake of argument Auto Tech
you learn how to work on cars in 10th
Grade 11th grade they decide they want
to focus on marine tech in senior year
which could include some work-based
learning um component or some study it
at the local community college so I
think that that the capacity building
potential is there and I think that we
could turn the lights on on a pathway of
course right now with a capacity as it
is
you're welcome
further questions
thank you very much Jeff you're very
welcome thank you
okay are there any other folks that want
to talk or speak or present on this bill
if not we're closing the hearing and
that bill is making changes to the
requirements for civics education in
schools
oh rep Senator Carson you're here I
didn't see you behind that I'm hiding
yes
Mr chairman would you like me to come
yeah for those that spoke
that didn't have to send a pink card
will you please do so so we'll have that
on record Jeff
Rey
okay
Sarah Carson you always been here before
talking about veterans or Veterans
Affairs or
Mr chairman I spent eight years in this
room as a House member so yeah I'm very
familiar not with this layout but when
the room was much smaller but it is a
pleasure to be back here
um in House Education
well thank you very much and you're
welcome to have the floor thank you Mr
chairman and uh good afternoon honorable
members of the House Education committee
for the record my name is Sharon Carson
and I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of Londonderry Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration this
afternoon Senate Bill 16 which seeks to
make changes to the requirements for the
Civics for civics education in school Mr
chairman as you are well aware because
you were here we have passed a Civics
requirement for our children in schools
that they must have before they graduate
but unfortunately we really didn't flush
it out too much and so what this bill
tries to do is set up those parameters
um so everyone is on the same page when
it comes to our students getting a
Civics education in our Public School
System
um Senate Bill 216 was written by uh was
written to establish a Civics education
commission as well
um Civics is quite frankly more than
learning about government Civics
encompasses how government works in
action and quite frankly Mr chairman I
don't know most people are aware of this
but I teach classes in government in
politics at a community college in our
state so I see a lot of the students
when they come out of public our Public
School Systems some of them have a
little bit of knowledge but the vast
majority of them just really do not
understand how our government works and
more importantly how they can access
government and I tell my students it's
important that you realize government
determines how we live our lives every
day it tells us what you can do and it
tells you what you can't do and so how
can you participate
if you don't understand it if you don't
know how you can make government work
for you and how you can let your voice
be heard
Mr chairman I went to public school a
very long time ago I'm not afraid to say
that and we were taught Civics we were
taught Civics beginning in Grammar
School
and for some reason and somehow it just
seemed to kind of drop off the face of
the map for a while but I think today it
is more important than ever that our
children learn about our system of
government and how it actually works so
they again can access it and be a part
um
we I firmly believe that the education
of all of our citizens is critical for
the development and advancement not only
of our state but of our country as well
and they must be equipped with knowledge
so they can stand up
and fight for what they believe is best
for our country and for our state
this is civics is a non-partisan subject
there's no you'll see there's no mention
of parties in there anywhere
this is truly about educating our
children so they can become good
citizens and knowing how to access our
systems
um it's important that students
understand that we have a two-party
system and why we have a two-party
system and how it has evolved over time
because if any of you have been a
political science students you know that
it's it's not straightforward it kind of
goes back and forth and around and
around and what was once a republican is
now a Democrat and what is now a
Democrat was once a republican in fact
there was once a party called the
Democrat Republicans
um and it helps to put that into context
when you're teaching Civics to children
to understand the background of the
evolution of our political system and
our and our government what it also
wants to do is really have students
develop critical thinking skills when it
comes to government to think
independently for yourself because when
you go in that voting booth whether
you're voting on a warrant article at
the local level with spending of money
or you're voting for candidates you want
to make what I tell my students is an
educated decision
how do you make that kind of a decision
well you look into the candidate you
meet the candidate and quite frankly
that's one of the great things about New
Hampshire is that every two years you've
got a whole bunch of people that are
running for office and quick there were
a lot of kids and young students that
are afraid to approach a candidate
and so I asked them I said look it's
somebody who's running for office in
your District reach out to them send
them an email ask them questions if they
don't respond to you that's an
indication right there
but it's important that they have those
critical thinking skills so they can
make those decisions and if we don't
give them the basic knowledge of our
government and how it works how are they
going to be able to make those kinds of
decisions if they don't even know where
to start
I tell students that they ask well how
can I get involved and I said well
that's up to you sometimes it's just as
easy as putting a lot a sign on your
front lawn or a bumper sticker on your
car letting people know that you support
a particular candidate you believe
strongly in that account in that
candidate or you can write a letter to
the editor of your local paper in
support of a candidate or go to an event
and a lot of students don't I didn't
know I could do that but I think if they
had this grounding in Civics they would
understand that our system works based
on participation
that our forefathers created our
government for them to participate we
tend to forget Mr chair that we started
out as a colony and we think of colonies
and Colonial and people were dressed in
nice little big dresses and the
gentlemen were wearing hoes and fancy
suits
but we did not have the ability to
govern ourselves
we had Colonial legislatures which over
time became more powerful than I think
what England had intended them to be but
that be that at his may they were
hamstringed they had no representation
in Congress I mean in Parliament
whatsoever nothing but most students
aren't taught that type of History just
so you know my degrees are in history
and early American history so I'm one of
those folks I start talking about and I
just kind of go on and on and on about
it but it does directly tie into Civics
because you need that background and
really what this bill tries to do is set
those parameters and get that necessary
education for these kids that's uniform
and so hopefully everyone's learning the
same thing there'll be a little little
variations of course but it's that basic
background that we're looking for this
um
came at the request of Administrators
and students I've had the pleasure of
attending a 603 Civics presentation that
was done in our state supreme court and
I can't tell you how pleasant it was to
see these young children
participating in our in our government
and it's it just really I think is was
just wonderful and I hope that this
committee if you have the opportunity to
attend an event for
um for this
um 603 Civic 603 that you do that
um it's great to see these kids
participate
um and so Mr chairman I could go on on
and on and all they I know it's a long
it's been a long day for you folks and
as a teacher I kind of know when it's
time to stop because I I could go on and
talk about the English Civil War and the
impact on yeah you don't need that so
anyway I hope the committee looks
favorably on this bill
um there are folks from Civic 603 here
that can answer your questions and again
I hope you look favorably on this Bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much are there any questions for the
senator
oh hands go up representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question this doesn't seem to have a
specific curriculum attached to it so it
does leave it up to the Local District
to develop their own
um it's my understanding that that is
part of it the bill was amended in the
Senate and I did not get an opportunity
to really purview that Amendment so if
that very well could have happened
um in the uh Senate education thank you
you're welcome represent McDonald did
you have your hand up thank you Mr chair
and thank you Senator Carson I would
agree with you that Civics rarely is not
taught the way that it used to be or
that it should be I see within this bill
specifically page two you have ABC right
at the top lines five for seven and it
says opportunities and responsibilities
for civic involvement in your experience
as a teacher would you say that students
who understand how government functions
are more likely to be involved and that
this this bill would have the positive
influence on increasing let's say voter
turnout or citizen participation in
government
yes I firmly agree that if you
understand it you'll participate thank
you
further questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I love a lot of this
stuff I I really love the idea of
expanding Civics the Declaration of
Independence and other things there's
one question I have that's a little bit
of a concern based on actually testimony
we heard just a little bit earlier in
the day when there was a bill that came
up and non-public schools were um
brought up and the Department of
Education seemed to testify that that
would that that would include
um such things as homeschool collectives
is that something that this bill would
be applicable to
um thank you for the question I really
cannot answer that
um because it was my understanding we're
looking at Public Schools so so
um this curriculum but again there are
folks here who probably can answer that
question for you I I just don't have the
knowledge and I'm not going to mislead
you thank you
I do have a question for you um
I was also a history major geography
major in that first degree
um and happened to write the main
studies curriculum which dealt with
social studies for grades K through 12
in Maine yeah down east spotted out
um I have a difficult time
divorcing and you've mentioned it
several times for example I'm talking
about Shay's Rebellion a rebellion
against taxes and all that in the state
next door to us right now or south of us
Massachusetts western Mass
um how do you divorce teaching history
Civics and government if you're going to
really and I noticed that you're you can
embed this in the Elementary grades as
you so desire that's wonderful idea
um why not why can't you do that in in
the in the middle school as well where
you have it you shall teach a course in
civics
um why not Civics slash government
slash history
Mr chairman you're preaching to the
choir okay I mean we can we can talk
about the ramifications of Shay's
Rebellion but at the same time talk
about the Whiskey Rebellion in Western
Pennsylvania that are directly related
yeah and the one thing that got George
Washington to put his uniform on again
and go out with a ragtag army because we
didn't actually have one at the time
out of the house uh I I don't get
involved in domestic situations Mr
chairman are there any further questions
from the committee
thank you very much Senator thank you
very much Mr chairman and thank you very
much to the committee
uh next individual we have up in I have
a laundry list I'm supposed to follow
here
good afternoon
good afternoon everybody thank you to
Senator Carson for being the prime
sponsor for this bill in the Senate and
thanks to all of you for considering
this really appreciate that
um
I come here today
um to speak about Civics education and
to ask you to support sb216
my name is Martha Madsen and I'm a long
time Public School educator
for the past decade I have worked in
different capacities for New Hampshire
Civics so I've been involved in the
Civic area for a long time now and this
is very exciting to have this kind of
consensus among Educators and citizens
um
so this more time on Civics bill has
originated out of a group
that has been meeting for a couple of
years called the New Hampshire Civic
Learning Coalition and our our goal was
to reach out to as many different kinds
of um shareholders or you know uh groups
that cared about this issue so I want
you to know that this isn't just sort of
New Hampshire Civics idea this has broad
support
um
um the New Hampshire school library
media Association the New Hampshire teen
Institute the New Hampshire bar
foundation and the New Hampshire Bar
Association
the New Hampshire school boards
Association strawberry Bank Museum
um
education departments at New England
College University of New Hampshire and
St Anselm College
the New Hampshire Council for the social
studies the New Hampshire Historical
Society the New Hampshire Association of
school administrators and I could go on
but I'm trying to be brief the
organizations that have come out
formally and support their boards have
voted in support my organization New
Hampshire Civics the New Hampshire bar
Foundation
officially supports this bill the Nea
New Hampshire the both unions in the
state also the AFT New Hampshire Carl
Ladd and Jerry frew from nhsaa our
supporters the League of Women Voters
the New Hampshire Council for the social
studies so we have the teachers on board
with this they're ready to do more
and the New Hampshire Historical Society
so there is Broad support and I'm just
going to tell you three of my favorite
reasons why this is so important there
are so many and you're going to hear a
lot of reasons today but my favorite
reasons and ones that are close to my
heart
Civics education has the potential to
unite our state and our country and to
help us move on together to solve
problems in spite of differences of
opinion
in a poll taken recently by Dr Frank
Lutz for civics now it was found that 56
percent of Democrats and 56 percent of
Republicans thought Civics education was
the best way to unify as a country and
move forward
um that is in you know in comparing it
to things like national service and
other other ways to to bring people
together
we know this is the second reason we
know that Civics and the social studies
in general
have been marginalized have been back
burnered for several reasons including
the enactment of the No Child Left
Behind
laws of federal laws um that started in
the early 2000s since that time about 20
years ago 44 of school districts have
reduced time for social studies
social studies receives the least amount
of instructional time in Elementary
grades when compared to the amount of
my third and the last one I will share
is that the preparation for civic life
was the original purpose of public
schools
um
our constitutional democracy won't last
without better and more Civics education
we know that students who receive
effective and high quality Civics
education as um
representative McDonald made reference
to they're more likely to vote
they're four times more likely to
volunteer and work with their neighbors
on community issues
they're more confident in their ability
to speak publicly and to communicate
with elected representatives
I want to call attention briefly
to letters of support for this bill
from The Honorable Chuck Douglas I will
distribute that later and the honorable
Steve Dupree
also two Civics teachers who are also
lawyers have written letters of support
Dan Marcus of John Stark Regional High
School and Christopher Herr of Concord
High School
so those will be distributed at the end
it's been really gratifying to observe
the consensus for this bill
that has emerged among these very
diverse stakeholders and it's been
really amazing to do Civics four Civics
and I thank you very much for your
consideration and your support
um and I'm
ready to take any questions people have
them thank you very much representative
cordelli thank you thank you for being
here
um I was wondering if you might recall
um a report that was done uh maybe 12 14
years ago about Civics instruction in
New Hampshire and I I believe Justice
from Justice Suiter and maybe even
Sandra Day O'Connor were involved in
that report
um and it reading this reminded me of
that because maybe you can correct me if
I'm wrong if you remember it but I think
it talked about New Hampshire leading
the nation and having Civics instruction
at every grade level beginning at
kindergarten level do you recall that by
any chance yes
um I'm not sure about a report but I
know that both Justice Suiter and um
just Justice O'Connor came to Concord
and spoke about the importance of civics
education and the danger
um of of having a citizenry that is
ignorant about how they can have their
voices heard how the government works uh
how dangerous that was
um so I don't know if that is what you
are making reference to but
um certainly you know the Supreme Court
Justices are very concerned it doesn't
matter if you know what
um side of the
um aisle you're on whether it's just a
Sotomayor um Justice Gorsuch they you
know Justice Roberts they're all very
concerned about this issue so it seems
to be
um important to them because they I
think they see sort of the results of of
not having it very clearly yeah yes
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
it's just for clarification
um
because I am familiar with with the bell
and and definitely needs to be on the
books but my question is in regards to
the assessments so every student who
takes a Civics course has to take a
locally developed assessment
and they're required to take the
Naturalization examination as well
to graduate I think that's what it is
right now in high school okay that was
my question this is it's now yeah um but
this is something different this is
focused on k through eight
um because
um
it's not enough to introduce a new topic
to students
um you know in their senior year when
they're halfway out the door
um I I want to respond also to the time
question about integrating with with
history and and
um you certainly can do that in
elementary school there's a little more
time in elementary school so we have to
integrate right with music with art with
literacy with classroom management there
are many many easy ways for for teachers
to do that and it's almost just a mind
shift and some really good professional
development I mean we have kindergarten
teachers who are teaching coding now so
if they can do that
um they were trained to do that they
didn't go to school you know to college
to learn about coding they were trained
by the stem Community to teach coding in
kindergarten they can do that so if they
can do that um
we can we can support our elementary
school teachers to integrate Civics into
what they are already doing
I don't know if I answered your question
um in the bill it does it it's the
expectation that it would be required at
the elementary level or just integrated
within the curriculum yeah this doesn't
have an assessment okay attached to it
although you know we didn't change the
other the high school
um policies at all okay but we're
proposing that it starts in kindergarten
we know that it's too late right the way
it is is done right now the other thing
about history is the history keeps
getting longer and longer yes and I know
my own my own kids they learned sort of
you know Colonial period through
um maybe reconstruction several times in
school they learned that over and over
and they never even got to Vietnam and
so what this is doing is saying yes
that's all important history is super
important but if we you know history
keeps getting larger we need to carve
out some time specifically for civics
because it's getting lost in the history
curriculum
um and it's really really important not
to say that you can't teach them in an
integrated way you can but it's not
always done and it's important that it
be focused on right now and it was
integrated in the past
um
as part of just teaching thank you
representative Meyer did you have your
hand
thank you for being here and thank you
for taking my question thank you we
currently have in the law
uh the teaching of government and Civics
that's noted here this expands it to the
elementary schools
but my sense is that the reason why this
has come before us
is that even though it's been in the law
it's not being taught enough
so my question is
why do you think the passage of this law
since it's already in the law
would demand greater teaching of it
well um
I think there was some confusion because
the the first iteration of this law that
I saw said no later than grade eight I
believe so there is a change within this
law I think there was some inconsistency
because elsewhere it talked about K-12
but in this lot we're making it
consistent so that it should be clear
that it should be getting in
kindergarten and it should be taught in
an integrated way
through great through grade five and
then in grade six seven or eight and
again there's flexibility there for
localities to do it however they want
but somewhere in those grades of six
seven or eight there should be the
equivalent of a half year of civics
and we know that middle school is a
great time to teach Civics because these
young people are starting to think like
adults
and yeah and and they're not jaded yet
you know like a senior in high school
might be like oh you know rolling their
eyes about whatever
um we know developmentally that middle
school is a really terrific time to
introduce cynics and I and
you know I don't think that's done in a
consistent way in our state thank you so
further a represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you Martha for joining us this thank you
and I know you've you've worked uh many
years on this and it's involved a lot of
people a lot of stakeholders and and
they're really really complement the
effort to to Really thanks but fourth I
think you know a a bill that really does
provide some comprehensive reforms and
improvements to our to the framework for
our Civics education both at the um at
the elementary middle and um and at the
high school level too
um but what I wanted to focus on was um
was it the is it the high school level
and there there is a um there is a
provision in existing law that uh Dr
cascadden I think had had
um had had uh asked about uh you said
yeah it's it's an existing law and uh
that provision came into being I think
two years ago uh maybe uh uh devoid of
any instruction devoid of any curriculum
it was just a graduation requirement
where um where every every High School
in order to graduate from high school
you had to get a 70 or better on 128
question naturalization exam and uh with
absolutely no curriculum behind it at
all and so
so I guess
um you know as part of any bill you can
amend existing language too
um the when that bill was presented to
us
um the prime sponsor said that the um
that the knowledge would just wash over
the students and I noticed you didn't
use that type of language at all when
talking about what students would learn
through from the Frank when the Frank
using the framework that that you've got
here but I do have a concern and um and
just want to ask you
on the on the first page will the half
year or how will the half year course
of instruction so this is on line 17
Civics in high school required for high
school graduation
and then the definitions of civics
um in lines 19 through 30. how will that
prepare students to take that high
stakes 128 question wash over me wash
the answers wash over me
um
naturalization tests required for
graduation well I think um
you know we can we can certainly have a
debate about pedagogy I you know my
personal opinion isn't really relevant
here we have worked really hard to
create consensus
um and so while I feel that um a
multiple choice test I personally feel
that that's not the best way to instruct
people I also know that testing drives
instruction so even if you have a really
poor test
if teachers are trying to ready their
kids for that test they can't help alert
something I don't have an objection to
people knowing facts I think facts are
important but if you don't know how to
use them and you're not critical about
where you find those facts and you don't
think about who is choosing those
questions you know which questions are
left out I think you know um but you
know we as a coalition did not really
monkey around with what was already
there we didn't go there
um and I you know I think that's for
another project what we were doing you
know today what we're doing today is
asking for more time to prepare students
not only to take that test but to
actually be good citizens and know how
to participate as they get older
um
I don't know if that answers your
question but it helps a lot yeah it's
not yeah it's this is a you know all of
this is is compromise and that's one
thing I don't think that you know
students are learning enough about is
that nothing like this isn't exactly how
I would put it right but this is what
the group
you know a couple of years of work has
put forth for now and we're not going to
get we're not stopping we're going to
continue to work but for now we feel
that um
whether it's for the test or whether
it's for being a good citizen or for
whatever reason we're going to have more
success if we start earlier and that
young people have that Foundation
foundational knowledge so that when they
get to high school they have something
to pull on they have some prior
knowledge to connect
to right and so it's going to stick and
they're going to remember it more it's
going to be more meaningful to them if
they have a context for it
great thank you very much represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
for being here for your testimony
um so obviously Civics is incredibly
important it's something that we need to
focus on and get into uh curriculum
um no disagreements there I believe you
said your group New Hampshire Civics
um very involved with this your
nonpartisan group yes um I did go to the
website real quick just to see exactly
what is happening
um and what is being recommended and
when I click on educator resources one
of the first things that comes up is an
article called what kind of Citizen the
politics of educating for democracy that
goes on to denigrate the conservative
view of the word citizen as narrow and
ideological
and insufficiently good for democracy
and Justice oriented so I guess my
question is exactly how nonpartisan is
this
this is completely completely
nonpartisan as you
um could see from the sport in the
Senate
um we've had speakers of all Stripes
come and speak and right I think that
was a Joel Westheimer event but we've
had Susan Collins come and we've had you
know that a republican appointed Supreme
Court Justices come to speak so we are
very aware that we need to be balanced
in our approach because otherwise we
don't have a lot of credibility right we
really do want
participation informed participation
but we do not have a political
orientation at all
thank you further questions represent
Allison oh thank you Mr chair and thank
thank you for taking my question and you
may not be the right person to to answer
this I'm going to ask you anyways okay
uh just I I like the way the bill is
laid out I like the requirements as a
former social studies teacher and now
being on this committee for for five
years
what we might want to happen in the
local schools and what does happen can
be two different things was there any
discussion with a lot of discussion on
all of this but was any of that
discussion uh about how do we know that
you know the high schools are teaching
what we thought they should teach or how
are they is there was there any
discussion about mechanism for trying to
figure that out one year down the road
two years down the road
um
we feel that our Coalition we have
people involved from the Department of
Education
um and uh you know superintendents and
people principals people who have you
know some some considerable power within
the structure and
um
so we feel that the Coalition will be a
good check to see if this bill is making
a difference if people if if teachers
are actually
teaching this and following through and
what the results are
so that's that's how we we're viewing
the Coalition as an informal body that
would be very Vigilant about this
thank you
any further questions
I'm just going to just ask it try to ask
it in the form of a question
and I think that either represent mile
or represent luno alluded to this
um we've had in fact it was Senator
dalessandro myself
who wrote part of this here and we stole
it from Ohio really and
we put it in because we felt that this
stuff wasn't being taught
I also remember when
Mary guile and Mary Heath were on this
committee at a time that's dating it
back a while and we have the Statewide
assessment
and the Statewide assessment was once
inclusive of social studies
and we're looking at the old Frameworks
which were developed for social studies
which background what 2008 thereabouts
six eight and and
um
so in those evidently become our
standards I guess
um so my concern is the question is if
in fact we've had some of this onboard
in-law
yeah how do we ensure it is taught in
these schools when the schools have the
responsibility for instruction and
curriculum we have the responsibility
for academic standards the way if we put
this note there but how do we do we put
forth another Statewide assessment of
some kind
or involve it in the annual Statewide
assessment or or there's lots of
different ways of assessing too you know
portfolios the whole nine yards so I
guess that's where I'm hung up yeah we
haven't really gotten to that yet
assessment is one of those policies on
the policy menu that we're you know
we've considered
um and I guess we feel that um that
right now the assessment is this
naturalization test that's a very high
stakes test it's attached to graduation
so we better get together if we're if
that's going to be the assessment we
better spend some time on it right we
don't want people not to be graduating
from high school
um but that yeah I think that's an
important question I personally love the
like a digital portfolio as an
assessment but again I'm not in charge
of everything so that would be my
preference is to have something that
that starts in kindergarten and sort of
tracks that person's Civic life Civic
learning through high school so
oh but again and what we want to do is
in a coalition is to be very supportive
of teachers and one thing that Carl had
asked for is a whole year before this is
implemented so that teachers and schools
can get ready and get up to speed
they're already doing a lot of things
and they're like saturated so um what we
want to do within the Coalition is make
sure that teachers and administrators
know about all the excellent resources
that are out there
um uh and and to really give them some
support some professional development to
make it easy for them to access
easy for them to implement these things
thank you represent Myler yeah thank you
for that clarification because uh
follow-up representative LED that's my
concern yeah is that you can you can
pass all kinds of laws you want to but
if there's nobody there to try to
implement that law
and then it just sits on the books and
it's in the shelf of indecision
basically so I I'm very pleased to hear
your commitment of your Coalition I've
checked with the the social studies
Teachers Association and they're
committed to this yes so I think if the
Coalition follows through with this then
in fact what you're saying in this law
that you're proposing then it will
happen because those are the
practitioners that are going to be
implementing it so right we've done the
work clarification sir we've done the
work and we you know not imposing
something but asking people
you know over two years trying to get
find something that people agree on and
this is what they've agreed on
um I think having buy-in will make sure
you know that's more makes it more
likely that people will actually
implement
and also providing support with that to
them
I'm just going to take a moment and read
the statute on this assessment because I
think that's important it says history
geography civics and economics remain
required critical areas of study
therefore assessment of these subjects
remains within the purview of the local
school board
so what we did because the state wasn't
assessing
we knocked it down at that time to the
local school board to ensure that it was
taught
there were people on this committee at
that time that didn't want to do that
either
however we didn't have the Statewide
assessment so we were just sort of in
this where do we go
so in order for this on and I I guess I
shouldn't I should be asking questions
uh that
would you believe that you need to or we
all need to
develop how we're going to hold people
accountable for for the subject of
civics
the future policy question right yeah I
think it's a future policy question I
think there is some accountability in in
the testing that's there already
um
and I think having buy-in and having
support will go a long way but
assessment is you know is is another is
another piece that we could look at
another time
so further comments or questions from
the committee here yes represent Damon
Mr chair
independent of that very credible and
I'm trying to make this into a question
um on lines 27 through 30 when you list
um
some examples of
topics to help with appreciation of free
speech and civil discourse
and reflecting on your observation that
your own children and I parallel the
experience with mine
had some repeated history learning over
time and therefore did not get to
current or more recent events very
I'd love to see the end of line 30
additionally say and contemporary or
maybe in current topics in civics
because 1960s well certainly a very
important part of civics is now a long
time ago and lots of things have
happened and will happen going forward
so that isn't a question we're living
the 1960s I lived it I did too I'm not
dissing the 1960s I'm just saying
there's yet more right it keeps getting
longer
anyway any further
comments or questions
thank you very much Martha thank you
very much Senator delis Andrew don't sit
down if you want to sit in the hot seat
thank you Mr chairman that distinguished
represents of the committee I apologize
for happy to leave but I had to provide
bill over across the or over across the
hall that we hopefully will get passed
for the record I've said it alludalos
who know I represent District 20. BHS
Awards two three four ten eleven and
twelve and I could be for you as as one
of the sponsors of the Civics piece of
legislation
now the chair and I have worked for a
number of years on Civics and try to
develop a Civics play in for our schools
particularly at the at the secondary
level this covers more than just the
secondary level it indeed I think it's
indicative of what's happening in our
country people don't know anything about
Civics they don't know anything about
government they don't know about the
structure they don't know how to
participate
and as a result we have chaos
and they must tell you that that what
we're witnessing what I'm witnessing
in terms of of the government of our
nation the governments around around the
world
is a a totally consistency a chaotic
situation
and
it's it's depressing to be uh
I taught I've taught Civics I've taught
it at Kennett High School at Conway New
Hampshire I taught it at Bishop Bradley
High School in beatchester New Hampshire
taught at New Hampshire college and
Franklin Pierce University and of Saint
Anselm College so I I I've spent my life
trying to inform people about what it is
to be a participant
and how important your vote is how
important your knowledge of the system
is how it works how it works and how it
functions for you and if you don't
participate
you can't complain
you just can't complain
you've got to be an active participant
in New Hampshire we're pretty good at it
particularly in presidential purpose we
get the vote out but I'll tell you
computable elections are a disgrace
we get very few people out a 20 turnout
sometimes an 18 percent turnout
that's that's ridiculous and what do we
do we complete we just look at the
newspaper listen to people talking of
the street and what are they doing
they're complaining why are they
complain anymore oh this lousy
government doesn't work
my taxes are too high
I'm not getting the services that I want
well you got to be a player you got to
participate
that you've you've got to be an active
participant and hopefully we could do
that we could excite uh young people
I've got three children I've got they
grandchildren I've got two
great-grandchildren
hopefully somebody in that crew is going
to follow follow uh followed by foots
episode to speak uh I have a daughter
who's very active in politics she's very
active around this legislature and I
think doing a good job her knowledge of
the system is is good in her ability to
interact with people is I I think
pronounced I have another
daughter-in-law who's a school nurse I
talked to her about her this morning
before another piece of legislation and
and she's working with kids on a daily
basis she's going to help kids out so
some of the treatably has has
participated and I just hope that we
could spread the word
just Enlighten people as the young
involvement in the process makes a
difference you make a difference I uh
you all you all have are here and uh uh
making a difference
you make any difference by your
participation
and your votes are going to be big
they're coming up but you're going to be
voting on the budget for the State of
New Hampshire hopefully we'll be working
on the Senate side
but unless we understand the process
unless we understand that how meaningful
participation is it's all for not
so I hope that we'll continue to pursue
a good Civics program you know I'd like
to see it K-12 obvious obviously because
we never stop learning
it it indeed the better the better we
are acquainted with the facts the better
the decision-making process will be in
at the better successful have it making
uh our City's better making our talents
better and and certainly our state's
better and uh we've got to have our
influence on the direction of the
country so with that Mr chairman I thank
you very much for your attentiveness and
appreciate it uh even though you
graduated from the University of Maine I
appreciate it I know I appreciate that I
appreciate the old Yankee conference
we'll make you an honorary black bear
okay thank you thank you very much I'll
have to take any questions thank you
very much Lou uh are there any questions
from the committee for the senator
thank you very much thank you appreciate
it thank you and thank you for your
kindness and your workload Civics bills
that your great work in education thank
you thanks
uh now we're going to go down through
this list Senator Khan that you provided
me
um so uh
okay
hello I'm Elizabeth Jewell I'm the
director of education at the New
Hampshire Historical Society
um we are a supporter of this bill
um and we have any good of a story I
just want to give a little context to
this
um the New Hampshire Historical Society
is one of the oldest non-profits in the
state
um we have had a dedicated education
program since 1964. we worked with
thousands of school kids every year
um at the moment our rubric with roughly
30 000 school kids in New Hampshire a
year
um they come through our program through
those field trips they certificate in uh
for elementary students and they worked
with us through that so we have a long
history of a lot of kids on which to
track Trends and see how things are
changing and things are changing really
dramatically
um and about 2015
oh sorry about 2015 or 2016 and we
started seeing a real change in the
students that we were working with their
understanding and knowledge of history
and Civics just plummeted it happened
very quickly it was very dramatic
um in response to this our Board of
Trustees decided to to dive in with both
feet we're very concerned about it we
started an initiative called the
Democracy project we raised 1.2 million
dollars to devote to it and we started
really kind of delving into this issue
which included a Statewide listening
tour with Educators to see what was
really going on what we found was that
the crisis is really at K-8 a lot of
attention is paid to Social Studies and
Civics at the high school level but that
isn't really where the problem is the
problem is at these younger grades and
the lack of foundational knowledge that
kids are getting and the marginally
marginalization of social studies across
the board
what we found when we talked to teachers
and Educators administrators library
media Specialists was that especially in
K-5 social studies is is not really
being taught in the vast majority of New
Hampshire schools anymore
um this was back in 2016 2017.
um time for social studies had virtually
disappeared in their school day with
block scheduling all the time was being
spent on English language arts and math
most schools had a 45-minute block per
week that was spent on social studies or
science and in practice teachers told us
it almost always went to science
um so in response to this we like I said
we raised the money we did a big
initiative to provide curricular
resources to provide professional
development to be a more active Advocate
on behalf of Educators and to work with
them and find out what they needed we
support this bill in particular because
there are two Provisions that are really
I think key here the first is we've
talked about it a little bit this change
in language between social studies or
history and Civics education should
start no later than eighth grade that
actually is some of you have alluded to
that actually contradicts what's in the
minimum standards right now which says
that social studies needs to be taught
at every grade level the problem is that
for many people RSA 18911 has been
revised and looked at so many time in
times in recent years that that's kind
of become the blueprint that they that
Educators look at when they're teaching
Social Science Education and so that
language is confusing it makes it sound
like it's actually
um optional before eighth grade when
it's not so by clarifying the language
you are sending a clear message about
the state expectations which have
already been set in the minimum
standards you're just emphasizing
reiterating those expectations
the second piece is that middle school
that half credit Middle School social or
Civics course which again is essential a
handful of states in America now require
a middle school course of this nature
New Hampshire should be one of them we
should be leading the country as we
already do in representative government
through town meetings through our
citizen legislature through the
presidential primary so we should be
investing in that because the truth is
as as Martha Manson already mentioned by
the time those kids get to high school
they need to have that basis of
foundational knowledge or they're not
going to be able to do in high school
the things you they need to learn to be
able to become fully functioning
citizens
so for all those reasons we support this
we support this bill wholeheartedly as I
mentioned some of you have asked
questions about how do we get people to
teach this how do we get it done in the
schools
um I did reference the new Statewide
social studies curriculum for upper
elementary schools called Moose on the
loose it's available online if you go to
the New Hampshire historical society's
website it's totally free it's totally
open access no accounts no passwords
nothing everybody in the state can get
on and see everything that's being
taught
and it provides that foundational basis
it shouldn't be all that's taught in
social studies other programs other
resources are very important to make a
really well-rounded education but we've
already started with non-profits like
mine non-profits like New Hampshire
Civics providing the kind of support
that schools need we need the state to
make a clear statement that you support
social studies education at grades K-12
thank you are there questions from the
committee
do you know if they're teaching in this
state I know we did when I was over in
Maine that in the fourth grade you all
teach Maine history and Civics and
government
is that occurring not Maine but New
Hampshire Civics and because it used to
be a fourth grade thing right and it is
traditionally that is when State history
has been taught and we we usually see
fourth graders as you all know right the
fourth graders come through here and
then they walk across the street and
come and see us at the New Hampshire
Historical Society we get a lot of field
trips still
um but what we were seeing more and more
was that teachers were telling us
instead of that experience being the
Capstone to a year-long study of State
history it had become the substitute for
it and for many of these students that
two-hour field trip was all they were
getting of State history
um social studies has been in Decline
for a long time and No Child Left Behind
was really The Tipping Point right
because the it only emphasized English
language arts and math now you're seeing
for a while schools try to keep it in I
mean educators are just as concerned
about this as the rest of us are they
tried to keep it in but it's been almost
it's been 20 years since that went in
and now we have a whole generation of
teachers who did not get social studies
education when they were in kids when
they were in school
so it's it's the problem is simply
compounding
um I know I've heard you know some of
your questions to to Martha I can sense
your frustration that we're not doing
more but at the same time it's kind of
like that old adage about how do you eat
an elephant one bite at a time I mean
you got to start somewhere and this is a
start something that we thought was
achievable that we had consensus around
bipartisan consensus that was a step in
the right direction there's lots of work
still to be done but this is a first
step thank you
thank you
for the question thank you very much
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
very much for having me
um
I have uh I wrote my thoughts down so I
wouldn't forget anything
um dear Representatives my name is Holly
Wilson and I am the winner of last
year's Mary Susan Leahy New Hampshire
Civics teacher of the year
8th grade US history and seventh grade
civics at Weir Middle School and I've
been an educator and Coach most of my
life
I also sit on the New Hampshire Learning
Coalition which wrote this bill
it continues to shock me that seventh
graders do not know the three branches
of government when they enter my civics
class in the fall
it shocks me to hear students Proclaim
with utter certainty that the president
has more power than anyone else in
government
it pains me to watch jaws drop in
astonishment when I teach about lynching
students can't believe this has happened
in our country
they know so little about our government
our rights as individuals and our power
to change the future why why is this
I know why
my own children attend a school district
that does not dedicate any class to the
sole subject of civics until they are
sophomores in high school
and this is a good school district
if they had not heard through
conversations at home about the workings
of our government
if they had not witnessed their parents
make the effort to vote
if their grandmother had not been a
selectman in the town where they lived
my children would not have understood
how government works until they were
teenagers
it's never too soon to help our children
our future leaders
to recognize and know the workings of
our constitution
like the national anthem we should teach
and reteach Civics year after year
we should teach and reteach what our
government looks like year after year
we should teach and reteach how to
become involved
specifically within our communities year
after year
imagine if students were exposed to
Civics each year of their education
those Snippets of civics remind me of a
quote from Desmond Tutu
do your little bit of good where you are
it's those little bits of good put
together that overwhelm the world
please support sb216 more time on Civics
bill
let's expose our youth to Civics from
grades K-12 and produce the next
thank you very much are there questions
as Civics teacher of the year do you
know of a curriculum that's out there
that's been written for elementary
schools
specifically for civics
well for for even social studies you
know you know it used to be a
requirement you had X number of minutes
per week taught in this subject area we
took that stuff out all over the country
and now we're sitting there as you say
because we don't measure in a Statewide
assessment I'm not held accountable for
a social studies so why teach it well I
can speak from what I see where I teach
and it is a it's a tremendous School
District I'm very proud of it but when
we have vertical meetings where all of
the social studies teachers come grades
four through eight in my school
the social studies Department in the
fourth grade doesn't know where to
acquire information there isn't
specifically things for them to utilize
we piecemeal together the New Hampshire
Council for social studies wants to be
an integral part of this bill in
providing professional development that
is the committee I'm sitting on we know
about the moose on the loose which is is
a wonderful program and teachers are
very good at doing research and finding
things that work for their students But
to answer your questions specifically I
do not know of something that is
specific in my district for Gades k-4
we used to have
various Powers Holton methlin Holt
Reinhardt Winston Scott forestman all
those that had programs specifically
built around social studies K through
12.
um have has that all disappeared well
our district has very specific what you
need to teach when but if you're asking
me where do we get that curriculum
you have creative teachers who teach too
we are competency-based district and we
know our competency what the kids have
to master and so we use the for the
resources that we can to teach to the
competency
thank you
rep Santana
thank you I'd like to congratulate you
on thank you my the greatest honor of my
life
super I'm sure I'm sure you would really
deserved it because it's been hard
teaching social studies the last few
years
um I'm wondering if if you use
Performance Based assessments if you do
activities rather than just sit and and
learn uh you know the different the
Declaration of Independence and that
sort of thing and if you could share
with us maybe a couple of things that
you do you would suggest in the Middle
School area for activities thanks
um
we are I have not given a traditional
test in seven years we are performance
task we call all of our summatives tests
um for old school where we call them
summatives now we call them performance
tasks they all revolve around something
that's realistic kids need to show their
knowledge through a project of some kind
and I understand what Martha was saying
about the the um naturalization exam is
uh much more um
it's just simple questions do you know
the facts can you answer the question
the way I assess my students is can you
take that information and you can can
you tell me how that works and you can
can you tell me the impact that has on
us today that's the highest score that
they can get it's not easy for them to
understand a lot of things
at that level in seventh and eighth
grade but they can they can and I assess
using fun things create a podcast and
answer these series of questions that
answer a series of depth of knowledge
um ranking from one to four one is one
number you know do you know what that is
do you know my name you just remember it
right all the way to four what is the
impact so I they create podcasts they
know how to build websites
um we sometimes do old-fashioned
newspapers how about a letter to the
editor
um kids don't really know what that is
um
Elka she's here in the background she's
one of my students what other things
have we done
posters
thank you very much yes representative
Damon
when thank you for taking my question
when are you going to publish the
curriculum you just described and can we
sit in on your class
I will tell you what the professional
development that New Hampshire Civics
has offered me and my colleagues that's
just one organization in this state is
outstanding I just had a great Zoom
professional development yesterday with
a social studies teacher in Milford
who's an Adjunct professor at UNH
talking about how do we teach democracy
in classrooms that are so polarized and
he gives concrete ideas and we feel like
we're politicians as teachers we need to
cross the aisle we need to I I don't
have an agenda to tell my students what
my politics are I want them to learn to
critically think and so we have to do
that kind of thing and yeah it would be
great if we could publish this
curriculum all in one place wouldn't it
be fun maybe I should write a book when
I retire but
we get ideas from lots of different
places and this Coalition plans on
following through my committee
individually as a small group wants to
be engaged in that where will teachers
go once they're told they need to do
this to get information we are going to
provide that
on the New Hampshire Council for social
studies is one of the largest proponents
that's an easy place to go to get free
information about how to teach something
here's an idea here's a lesson plan
so you don't have to do any work it's
just right there
repson cordelli
thank you and thank you for being here
and congratulations
um thank you back in 2016. well I guess
goes to the question of
um how do we know what is actually being
taught or if things are actually being
taught back in 2016 we passed a statute
that said the history of the Pledge of
Allegiance and Star-Spangled Banner
should be taught do you know if that's
uh it is being taught
um
specifically I can speak to my district
we don't have such specific
um
we have learning targets underneath our
competencies which last year we just
narrowed down
Ela had 56 learning targets science had
128 and it was almost impossible to
reach them all
um
but we try our very best we understand
what we need to teach but
is it actually for me specifically
stated no I need to teach that they
understand government that's pretty
vague and that gives me a wonderful
platform from which to jump
thank you
no further questions thank you very much
thank you good afternoon for the record
Megan Tuttle president of New Hampshire
I will keep this short because I know
there's a long list it's late there's
still more bills and I don't know how I
can follow that
um so I just I have written remarks and
I'm going to turn them in I'm completely
going different though listening to
what's been said I was a social studies
teacher for 18 years eighth grade social
studies U.S history from Colonial times
through reconstruction so everything
we're talking about is what I did for 18
years
I guess what I really just want to say
here um
I have three boys I've mentioned that
before they're in public school they're
currently fourth Sixth and tenth grade
when my 10th grader was in fourth grade
one of the things that I had my eighth
graders do was we taught um they learned
about New Hampshire history through me
so that they could come into my son's
fourth grade class and teach them about
New Hampshire history and government in
preparation for the State House Tour
that they were going to take that year
so when you asked about assessments
things like that that's something that
one thing that I did as a project I knew
my eighth graders knew the material
because they taught it to somebody else
and they taught it to other kids and so
that's one way that we knew it was
happening
um
we also did a lot with differentiated
learning and I did a lot with it was
kind of an upside or a triangle where
the sea level was where the kids got the
basic knowledge they would learn
vocabulary just basic information in
ways that fit their learning style so we
had a calendar they could pick their you
know the way they wanted to learn it
they gained points the B level was
smaller but that's where they applied
the knowledge and then the a level the
top of it is where they answer the
answer the essential question for the
unit
there's a lot of ways that we can assess
them without doing a state test and it
works because there was no written test
for this it was all through can they
talk to me and so we had conversations
if they can explain things to me I know
they're not just memorizing I know
they're not just spitting you know back
information that they read from a book
or you know learned from flashcards or
whatever so there's lots of different
ways to do this
I think the big thing here is we need it
back in the classroom we need Civics
back in the classroom in all the grade
levels it was easy to Let It Go when No
Child Left Behind came around because
the importance was put on English math
reading we've been through all this so I
don't want to rehash it but that's what
happened we need to get it back into the
classroom this bill is going to allow
that to happen the Civics Coalition
working with Martha working with
Elizabeth working with everybody is
amazing and so I will pass in my written
testimony but you know as an eighth
grade social studies teacher we need it
back in the classroom kids were coming
to me not knowing everything that was
just spoke about and that's awful for
the future and I really just honestly
want all kids to get what my kids get
which they don't appreciate yet but when
they're a captive audience in the card
and they will someday hopefully the
captive audience in the car 10 minutes
they're getting you know U.S history
they're getting labor history
unfortunately because of my job they're
getting Union history they're getting
all that but they're getting that
because they're stuck in the car with me
me every child should have that right so
I'll leave it at that thank you very
much Megan are there any questions from
the committee yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
Megan for joining us and um you know I I
um
a question I'd sort of like to get out
with you and I don't know if if the
chair would would allow Holly Wilson to
to join you up here but it was something
based on what she said but they're both
teachers here so all right Holly where
are you oh but Holly made Holly made a
fantastic comment and I think you you
touched on it as well Megan which the um
the a lot of the directives that that we
have in statute and you use the term
vague and I like that but it gives you a
large platform for which to to jump and
I I took that correctly if I'm wrong as
being a positive
um thing as opposed to something so
granular like like you've got to teach
how some you know the history of this
specific thing or that specific thing
and and so you know just in the last
just in the last week or so you know we
passed bills requiring teachers to teach
cursive instruction great I don't know
what five or something like that or or
multiple you know memorizing
multiplication tables as opposed to we
want our students to learn intuitive
strategies to understand math you know
things like like that but bringing it
back to 216 are the are the directives
here
um
that um
that are sort of on the bottom of of of
the first page of the bill would you
consider those
um in your sort of professional
experience to be sufficiently broad or
vague in order to provide you with that
with that large platform with to to
reach your students
I think so
um I I like that we've suggested such as
and I really like what uh Senator
representative Damon said about adding
more current uh beyond the 60s and it's
a goal that uh
yes I I think that it is
there is enough room for teachers to
bring their their own talents to the
show and
choose the best way to teach certain
things and maybe combine some of these
subjects
um and maybe skip one because they run
out of time they'd like to get to
January 6 2021 before they're going to
talk about Federalist Papers kind of
thing sure sure great thank you very
much Holly and thank you I was just
going to say I agree with you know it
says such as and this gives kind of what
could be taught but gives you the
openness to bring other things in
great thank
you any further questions for Ms Tuttle
come back I can go sit down at you she's
in the classroom right now still so
um just because you are representative
of the teachers in in the field it has
been my concern about the number of
um legislative curricular items so keep
getting passed down to districts versus
allowing local school districts to make
those decisions I believe in cursive
handwriting absolutely but it went away
and why is it because something else
took its place I mean I know our
teachers are inundated today between
technology and whatever else is added
are you hearing in the field that adding
civics
I mean are people saying well when are
we going to do it I mean we still have a
five and a quarter hour day or two or
six hour day depending on the levels
um
I think Civics should have never gone
away but I can remember in the 2016 era
when Common Core came out
it's we we made a decision not to buy
any more textbook series because you had
to cut the budget anyway we'll get
enough money but also integrating it
with language arts and reading so that
you hit the topics at the same time as
you're teaching reading obviously that
did not work because you weren't
spending enough time on content of
civics
and I just wonder if teachers in the
field have expressed that to you because
it is a huge concern of mine and I think
other things need to go and Civics needs
to be there without a doubt and I thank
you for the question what I'm hearing is
Elementary it's always going to be hard
to put something back in that's been
taken out because
the focus has been on math reading and
writing for so long I don't think it's
impossible I think it can definitely be
done we just need to help the elementary
school teachers figure out how to you
know get Civics back in the classroom
Middle School
8th grade seventh grade sixth grade
right we have specialized subjects so
it's a lot easier and from what I am
hearing especially middle school high
school it would be nice to have
something to point to to say guess what
we we do need to do this it's important
right and I think that this will also
help the elementary school teachers who
are kind of saying okay but we have to
focus on this this and this because of
the test this is going to be something
to point to them now two different hats
to wear on curriculum mandates coming
down from the state I have my teacher
hat I have my you know Nea New Hampshire
hat
um
it would this the way this is written is
good because it gives Direction but it
doesn't specify you have to for example
like you were mentioning memorize
multiplication right teach it not
memorize it right so you know giving
some Direction
but having it in statute that the
directions there which I know it's in
there but this is just moving it forward
if that makes sense just want to make
sure the perception from the teacher's
point of view is we can do this from
what I'm hearing yes but I'll definitely
someone who's in the classroom is home
thank you
um I think if teachers understand that
they need to touch on Civics during
these grades they can integrate it and
I'll give you a classic example I was
teaching US History not long ago
teaching about World War II Japanese
internment camps the Holocaust and boy
that Japanese internment camp turned
right into
what about our first 10 amendments what
about the rights of those people they
can just go and take their houses they
can take their they can do this
and there's Civics right there I stopped
the the lesson and we just went in that
direction because they had already had a
stomach so they did know generally how
our government worked but it's like how
did they get away with that so teachers
can do that if they're creative but if
they know they have to it's much easier
to integrate it into what you're already
teaching I think
before you leave ladies I have a sort of
a follow-up here
um I hate the dragons but I
we we have elementary teachers they're
going to post-secondary education and
getting their tickets to be a teacher
and you might get a methods course in
how to teach social studies
you don't have to have anything else
unless you've taken a gen Ed Course your
general education that's more your
liking my concern are are these
elementary teachers that have come out
of this situation of the classes since
we've talked about 2016 it's kind of
been a divorce avoid of a subject are
they coming in with a knowledge and
understanding that this is something we
should be teaching are they being told
that at this post-secondary level
um how is it being taught there and I
see some some that are shaking their
heads like this and and
um I'm really concerned there's nobody
here from our post-secondary systems
nobody in this crowd and they never
attend unless there's something directly
affecting freedom of speech in the
college campus
so I I am concerned that we really you
know try to get in to find out the
reasons why it's not being taught
the way that I think we all feel it
should be
thank you I completely agree with that
and I've testified before in other
things in the past few years that
pre-service is just as important the
pre-service programs are just as
important when we talked about suicide
prevention and you know having to do the
trainings and everything everything that
we're doing in the field it needs to be
going back and this actually ties in
with the educator shortage I mean
there's a lot of things that tie into
this so I completely agree with that I
think you know conversations with the
colleges the pre-service programs has to
include things like this I do think that
the middle school as you were talking
about with the groups of teachers
meeting the middle school meeting with
the elementary school teachers and
letting them know this isn't coming up
the kids aren't coming up learning this
um how can we help you we have the
Civics Coalition that has amazing
resources and we just need to be making
sure as Educators together you know
through us through them through other
groups that we're we're letting them
know about this um that these
opportunities are out there so that just
like Martha mentioned they are learning
coding in kindergarten teachers didn't
go to school to teach coding but they're
doing it we can do the same thing with
Elementary School teachers for civics
thanks Megan
no further question thank you very much
it's okay
Caitlyn Roca by the way uh
I had on this list but I didn't get a
card for Elka
where he was Elko going to speak today
or not
but it's right after your name
and but I didn't get her I didn't get a
do
good
well hello uh my name is Caitlin Rocca
Fuller
I'm a current uh freshman at UNH I'm
dual majoring in political science and
Justice studies I graduated from Exeter
High School in the spring of 2022.
um I'm from Ware Middle School I'm in
well I appreciate you all being here
today and I come in support of Bill SB
216. I'm a part of the New Hampshire
Civic Learning Coalition and have been
involved in this process since I was a
junior in high school it's been
absolutely amazing to hear my voice
really being heard by so many adults in
the room and being taken into
consideration and such important
legislation it touched me and I watched
as we really wrestled with problems of
how to make this bill bipartisan how to
support teachers how to make parents
comfortable and really to make sure the
students get the best education that
they deserve
okay I'll just continue
um really many students loved government
class in high school it was one of their
favorite courses they ate the
information right up and it was
refreshing to them to have more of an
understanding of how their government
worked but it was one semester in high
school so it doesn't really stick moving
forward as much as it should as much as
it needs to but I think the focus really
should be on students want to learn this
information I had the opportunity in my
senior year of high school to go to a
couple fifth grade classes uh during
Constitution Day and talk about how the
Constitution is still relevant and why
it's important to be an involved Citizen
and know your rights and your
obligations as a part of your community
they loved it the room was electric they
were raising their hands coming up with
ways that they can get involved next and
the teachers emailed me afterwards
saying that that's all I could they
could talk about for the rest of the day
this is
um really a skill that students need to
learn moving forward because Civics is a
skill and it's not really being taught
as a skill
um we see
and our education system with science
and English we see academic paired with
the ability to use it in everyday life
we have labs and science to complement
the facts that we're learning we're not
just pushed into the world not knowing
how uh to provide a hypothesis and being
able to come up with a procedure to be
able to prove it or find out we were
wrong
uh similarly with English we don't just
learn vocab or grammar we learn how to
write an essay we learn how to formulate
an argument the same as with Civics we
need to have the basis and learning the
facts what each article in our U.S
Constitution and our state Constitutions
are and then being able to go forward
and make sure our voices are heard I
being able to sit here and talk about
such a bill as a college student is
amazing and I'm only able to do that
because I was involved in the beginning
this was something I was passionate
about and I would like to see this
opportunity given to students who this
might not be their first thought of what
they want to do but they're passionate
about something maybe that relates to a
career they want to go into and a bill
comes up or they want to
write a bill about changes that they
feel need to be seen this needs to
provide be provided to all students so
they know
what they how they can be involved
moving forward outside of high school
and even in college I have many friends
who don't know what
um branch of government is set up in the
Third Article of the Constitution and
that's college students and luckily I'm
in a class where they're being taught
that but not everybody goes to college
and everybody deserves that information
that's all I had to say thank you
um
so I was one of 13 winners of the speech
challenge last year it's a civic
education opportunity where students
write a speech to help solve an issue
that's important to them
although I currently attend Ware Middle
School I was homeschooled up until last
year
public school gave me a lot of
opportunities that I didn't have before
and I've always loved been the kind of
person who loves to be involved
last year may have been my first year in
public school but it was also one of my
most successful partially because of
civics
Cemex was one of those classes that
everyone looked forward to it was always
fun and we knew that it was important we
learn things in Civics that we can use
in everyday life
it gave us the power to fix problems and
address issues using our own brains and
opinions
but most of all I think he gave us hope
most kids in this day and age have grown
up in a world where adults tell us it's
up to you
it's up to you to stop climate change
it's up to you to make sure everyone is
equal it's up to you to solve the Mental
Health crisis that this world is facing
it's up to you to fix all of the
problems that past Generations have
created and someday you will have to do
it all alone
hearing this from adults even the ones
who I know are doing everything they can
to help is a lot of pressure
hearing this can make kids want to give
up
especially if you have no idea how
attainable it is to begin solving these
problems especially if we have no idea
what our rights and responsibilities as
Americans are especially if we have no
idea how our government works and how we
can get civically involved in order to
make these changes
especially if we have only two years or
even one to learn everything we can
about the mechanics of our government
how can we do all of that without the
tools gained by receiving Civics classes
frequently
Civics has shown me how anyone can take
part in governing their Community even a
13 year old somewhere in New Hampshire
Civics taught me not only about the
problems of this world but how I can fix
them
giving students plenty of chances to
gain knowledge of the Constitution the
three branches of government our economy
and so much more will help students grow
up to be civically minded adults who can
properly navigate future America and its
complicated government
now I'm still a student so I don't
really know how much more time we need
to spend on this I only need no we need
more
please give students the time they need
to learn about how our government works
give students the tools to problem solve
and form our own opinions rather than
conforming to the social agenda of the
adults in our lives
give students the time they need to
learn the many responsibilities and
rights that come with being a citizen of
America
please give us the opportunity to fully
understand the structure of the
government that we will someday be
responsible for managing thank you thank
you very much are the questions from the
committee
thank you very much
oh you have a question representative
Cornell just just a question what did
you write your your speech on that you
won the contest with how can we help
fix and limit climate change using
cafeteria so like composting and
donating the extra food that's packaged
thank you
is this working properly okay
uh good afternoon my name is Anne-Marie
Banfield I'm a parental rights Advocate
focused on excellence in education
today I come here opposed to sb216 which
might kind of surprise you after so much
testimony but I do think it can be
amended and possibly passed
I'll just explain some of the problems
that I have with it and hopefully it can
be amended in past
I want to first start by saying that a
quality content-rich academic education
in Civics is a priority that I support I
do not believe that sb216 as it is
written right now offers that to
students in New Hampshire
it starts off with language that
supports a good quality academic civic
education at our school and I think
that's good
however then it directs Focus away from
academic content to focusing on other
activities
and I will point to if you're looking
for that IB
lines 23 24 through 30. so basically b c
and d are what I have an issue with
in the original Bill these were labeled
as Civic skills Civics dispositions
and Civics Behavior
and while I do appreciate the Senators
amending the original Bill to change the
language I do still see a problem
including b c and d
so what is wrong with students acquiring
skills such as the ability to analyze a
text and determine the reliability and
basis of sources
and just like competency-based education
competencies were to be focused on
skills too today we are seeing
competencies focused on measuring social
and emotional dispositions that means
that they are measuring and sharing
non-academic skills that are based on
Behavior attitudes values and beliefs
how do you measure all this subjectively
it was before this committee and I think
representative lead may have been the
only one in the room with me at that
time because it was a long time ago
but we had bipartisan opposition to
measuring dispositions with competency
but education
so if you're going to include skills
then you need to explicitly spell it out
what skills exactly do you want to put
if you offer suggestions in the RSA that
leaves the door open to subjectively
measuring all kinds of skills
dispositions and behavior some of this
should also be placed in the social
studies academic standards
for instance analyzing a specific text
could be included in standards standards
writers have an extensive background in
the course subject and they have the
ability to drill down to what should be
included in terms of Civic skills then
those standards are presented to the
public where we get to weigh in and make
the argument to keep the standards or
remove them ultimately the State Board
of Education would then make the final
decision
we have heard a lot today about what the
problem in Civics is and that is
illiteracy
the what children don't know we've heard
testimony today what they don't know
good quality Civic standards and tests
are the key to improving Civics
education in New Hampshire that is where
we should be focusing our attention
adding non-academic suggested skills
behavior and dispositions no matter how
good they are can be ignored or Worse
Twisted into something that all of you
have no intention on twisting
I also have concern I think
representative Belcher brought this up
uh is this going to be a mandate for
that needs to be clarified I don't think
Senator Carson would clarified that I
certainly do not understand and I would
oppose this being part of private
schools
there are many voices that contribute to
education reform in this country for
those who are familiar with Diane ravage
a prominent education historian who has
an enormous following of public school
teachers across the country she
addressed the skills movements and the
aft's American Educator magazine in
Spring of 2010.
this accounting of the many attempts to
remold public education into skills
training is worth reading and I am going
to give you a copy of that particular
article I hope every one of you read it
because it is a historical accounting of
this Reform movement and you need to
understand it I'm going to include the
entire piece with my testimony but I'd
like to read some of what she wrote
Because this again is Shifting Focus
away from academics to skills and other
behaviors so here's what she says I am
this historian of education and have
written often about the education
enthusiasms and fads in the past Century
one of my books titled left back tells
the story of the rise and fall of one
fat after another across the 20th
century in brief what I found is that
the in the land of American pedagogy
Innovation is frequently confused with
progress and whatever is thought to be
new is always embraced more readily than
what is known to be true thus
pedagogue's policy makers thought
leaders facilitators and elected
officials are rushing to get aboard 21st
century skills Express train lest they
appear to be old-fashioned or
traditional these terms
being the worst of a program that can be
hurled at any educator
for decade after decade pedagogical
leaders called upon the schools to free
themselves from traditional and subject
matter
Cubberley Edward Elwood P Cubberley
while dean of the education school at
Stanford warned that it was dangerous
for a society to educate boys and even
girls without reference to vocational
ends whatever they learned he insisted
should be relevant to their future lives
and work this sounds familiar doesn't it
he thought it foolish to saturate them
with a mass of knowledge that can have
little application for the lives which
most of them must inevit inevitably lead
they were sure to become disappointed
and discontented and who knew where all
of this discontent might lead coverly
called his fellow Educators to abandon
their Antiquated academic ideals and
instead to adapt education to the real
life and real needs of the students this
was in 1911. when she goes on to give
more examples the federal government
issued a major report on the education
of black students in 1916. its author
Thomas Jesse Jones scoffed at academic
education
which lacked relevance to the lives of
these students and was certainly not
adapted to their needs Jones wanted
black children to learn by doing
which was considered to be the modern
scientific approach to education
it was not knowledge of the printed page
that black students needed wrote Jones
but knowledge of gardening small farming
and simple Industries required in
farming communities Jones admired
schools that were teaching black
students how to sew cook Garden milk
cows lay bricks Harvest crops and raise
poultry
this was a prescription for locking the
South's
African-American population into menial
roles for the foreseeable future as
Jones acknowledged in his report the
parents of black children wanted them to
have a an academic education but he
something similar happened in many high
schools in the 1930s where many
avant-garde school districts replaced
courses like science and history with
interdisciplinary courses which they
called Core curriculum or social living
some districts merged several
disciplines such as English social
studies and science into a single course
which is focused not on subject matter
but on the students life's experience
does this sound familiar because we're
doing a lot of this today
in a typical class students study their
own homes made maps and scaled drawings
and analyzed such questions as the cost
of maintaining the home the cost the
cost of fuel light and power and how to
prepare nutritious meals but there were
occasional parent protests in Roswell in
rosin Roslyn New York parents were
incense because their children couldn't
read but spent an entire day baking nut
bread
the Rosalind superintendent assured them
that baking nut bread was an excellent
way to learn mathematics
in the early 1990s to move up
if you're not familiar with the scans
report everybody should be knowledgeable
with this
1990s bought bought scans the
secretary's Commission on achieving
necessary skills again back to skills
which recommended that exactly the kinds
of functional skills that are now called
21st century skills I'm sure you've
heard that term
these documents were produced by a
commission for the U.S Secretary of
Labor and she's speaking here and she
says I recall hearing the director of
scans say that students didn't need to
know anything about the Civil War or how
to write a book report these were
obsolete kinds of Knowledge and Skills
when the scans recommendations appeared
in 1991 I was an assistant Secretary of
the U.S Department of Education I
discussed them with David Kearns a
deputy secretary who had been CEO of
Xerox I said David the scans report says
that young people don't need to know how
to write a book report they need they
need to know how to write advertising
jingles
he replied that's ridiculous we can't
write advertising you can't write
advertising Jingles if you don't know
how to write a book report
there's much more to this article but
I'm not going to continue because it's
long but it's well worth reading
like you can clearly see the elitism in
this kind of viewpoint
who's going to get those manual
positions and this is why we're dumbing
down our Public Schools
this is what's behind the skills versus
knowledge movement that she details in
this historical article
so these for these reasons I urge you to
vote it on 216 however as I said I do
think it could be amended I do have this
article
um
you asked what the problems were to get
this taught or or why we have narrowly
focused and we're not focusing on this I
think some of the information was
presented there's no standardized test
what gets tested gets taught
I what whether you agree with standard
testing or not
I think that is a beeping component as
to why this is not being taught in
schools
and then action Civics what I am seeing
in our schools is a lot of action items
kids can do this and they can do this
but if you have the knowledge I mean how
do you apply the knowledge even Diane
ravich wrote an article years ago in the
New York Times I think it was about you
need knowledge first before you can
apply it
so everything that in that's in this
bill
up until that section I think is good I
think what what they're putting in here
makes sense although I have to tell you
as I'm looking at D where it says and
the Anti-Federalist
papers Federalists has anybody read
those yeah
that's seventh and 8th graders
do you remember what that do you
remember reading that can you imagine
seventh and eighth grader reading that
and believe me I think everybody should
read them before they before they
graduate high school but that is very
difficult that is an extremely difficult
read for seventh and eighth graders and
there's even discussion on what should
be changed up on on D so I I just have
the problem with b c and d
thank you very much are there questions
thank you very much thank you
hello everyone thank you so much for
letting me come speak today as a social
studies teacher this is a dream to be
able to come and practice what I preach
um so I am Haley Goodwin I teach 8th
grade social studies I've also taught
grades 6 through 12 and it's really fun
to be here because I was on the more
time Committee in the New Hampshire
Civic Learning Coalition so I feel like
this is my baby now growing up to be a
teenager an adult you know sitting here
and watching this unfold it's just
really amazing
um so I'd like to talk to you about why
this bill is so important first I'd like
to talk to you about Civic knowledge and
how Civic knowledge has decreased over
the last five years that I have been an
educator so hopefully I can wake you up
a little bit with some of the things
that I'm about to say
um I've had students who do not say or
know the words to the Pledge of
Allegiance who believe that the country
of Mexico is located in Wisconsin do not
know the name of their own state or
where to find it on a map believe that
Thomas Jefferson was an Explorer can not
correctly identify the president or vice
president of the United States believe
that there are 36 States and stars on
the flag cannot tell you where the
Atlantic and Pacific Oceans are believe
that their town is actually New
Hampshire no idea why we celebrate the
4th of July and I think the worst one
that I've received so far is when we
were talking about the Senate a
student's like oh I know the Senate
isn't his name Bill Gates or something
like that and this is coming from a 14
year old
my students do feel confident that they
know the difference between a Republican
and a Democrat and to them that means
that the opposite party is the enemy or
a stupid person in their words
I had a conversation with a student last
month we'll call her Sally and we have
just a general conversation are you
proud to be an American she says no I'm
not proud to be an American because I'm
French Canadian I said oh so were you
born in Canada you're not trying to dig
deeper Jesus no I was born in New
Hampshire I said oh well maybe were your
parents born in Canada you know trying
to get some information no they were
born and raised here too so I had a 14
year old student who did not understand
that she was a citizen of the United
States now the problem here was not just
her lack of knowledge but also the fact
that she was unwilling to have a
conversation with me to understand that
she is indeed a citizen of the United
States you see Civics is much more than
just basic content knowledge it is skill
and application of that knowledge as
well as the understanding of core
virtues that this nation was founded
upon
teachers are seeing the consequence of
the lack of civics education on a daily
basis and this can be seen in today's
teacher shortage
many teachers are leaving the field due
to Rising behavior issues and the lack
of Civility and respect kids show to
teachers and to each other
students do receive an education on
virtues and how to behave but that does
not come from parents and doesn't always
come from teachers but it comes from the
internet and Tick Tock where my students
say that their heroes are people like
Andrew Tate who say that you must be
loud and aggressive in order to win and
conquer
my classroom is full of kids who have
been shouting L's and W's because it's
good to be a winner and bad to be a
loser they have no idea how to have a
civil conversation by the time they get
to my classroom
so going back to the conversation when I
talked with students are you proud to be
an American I learned that either they
are not proud to be American or they are
afraid to be they are afraid that
showing love for their country means
that they are racists and hateful bigots
and this makes me sad and scared for our
country
there is a difference between patriotism
and nationalism and we need to be able
to teach that expressing love hope and
appreciation for the red white and blue
does not and should not lead our
students to think hateful thoughts of
one another we need to teach that the
red white and blue is what unifies US
now this bill does not tell teachers
what lessons to teach how to teach or
how many exact minutes each day to teach
it is however a declaration that Civics
is important and that we people of New
Hampshire need to stand up and show the
nation that Republicans and Democrats
can come together to teach our students
that Civic virtues and Civic knowledge
is desperately needed
now this December I'm getting married
I'm very excited to my fiance who's also
a social studies teacher and while we
are very excited to start our lives
together we also have a fear of what's
going to be happening to us as we get
older we're fear looking at our current
Generations what's going to happen to us
when we get older is these people lead
our country and Lead our nation
I miss the days where past Generations
look to the Future ones with hope that
they can fix it and make the world a
better place
right now I don't have that hope based
on what I see and I want to find it
again
we have messed things up and we need to
start preparing a new generation to take
on our responsibility and to keep the
world running
now I have uh sat here and listened to
questions being asked and as someone
who's been through this process from the
beginning and as a teacher who's been in
the thick of it I would love to answer
any questions that you might have even
if they are repeated thank you Haley any
questions from the committee
representative corneli thank you thank
you very much for being here and your
work as a teacher
um
I I take it you've you've read the bill
and heard the testimony I was just
wondering if if based on your experience
you'd have any suggestions on revisions
to the bill
that's a great question
um I think that this is the start I I
wouldn't revise it as it is written now
um when we were writing this and looking
at the language you know putting in the
Declaration of Independence it was not
in here originally I think that's really
important and there might be some things
that we are missing that we do believe
need to be taught such as like I
mentioned the Declaration and I would be
more than happy to see suggestions to
that but as others have said this is a
start and
um I wouldn't change a thing at this
point I think that there could be
additions later to support Civics
um but I believe that you need to have
both the knowledge and the skills coming
together because you can't have one
without the other they really need to go
hand in hand as I mentioned they can
know who the president is they can know
how many states there are and how many
stars are on the flag but what does that
matter if they can't sit down and have a
conversation with each other in a civil
Manner and I think that we need to be
able to teach both of those things in
our classroom
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you Haley
for taking my questions I obviously know
your school quite well I spent 32 years
there
um and during that time there was a lot
of uh fighting over how what would be
taught at the elementary school there
wasn't enough time to do anything social
studies and science or even like it was
tough you know we kept talking about
integration and and when we had World
languages they tried to add that it was
a fight with uh specials because if you
want to put World Language so my
question to you is
um it's a dedicated class time so grades
one to four yes what do you see that
looking like are you looking at you know
an hour
an hour a year or an hour a week how do
you see that playing out if it was my
own personal opinion
um I would love to see at least an hour
a week right now we don't even see that
in most elementary schools across the
state but I think if we come together
across disciplines to say that this is
important
um so my Civics knowledge came from my
mom who was a music teacher and and she
was my music teacher for eight years and
I remember marching around the classroom
learning patriotic songs and and
learning about the Star-Spangled Banner
and its history
um and that was my Civic knowledge I
didn't get it from my elementary school
teachers as much as I did from some of
my specialist teachers you know you've
got a picture of Chris uh Chris
McAuliffe on the on the wall behind you
and what an amazing way to bring Civics
together with science and math and so I
think if we get some camaraderie around
this knowing that it could support our
students and even their behavior and how
they're acting out in class I think that
we'd gather a lot of support to get even
more than one hour a week I'm just
looking at what's the minimum we can get
because right now we have almost nothing
and it just makes my heart so sad
um the more we can get the better I
don't think that you should put a time
limit on it just the more the merrier
follow-up yes so so whatever they do is
good whatever and you're lucky that they
do teach cursive writing in both so
that's not going to go by the wayside
but um so any any time is better than no
time I I do believe any time is better
than no time and you know part of this
is allowing for local control and
allowing the districts to say what does
that look like now I have my own
opinions of what I think that should
look like and I'm sure you do and all of
us do but this bill was written in a way
to support local control and I want to
honor that and and specify that I don't
think that that should be put into this
Bill thank you very much thanks thank
you for the questions now see thank you
very much thank you
thank you Mr chairman and it's a nice to
see familiar faces and see how this
process is continuing forward
um I'm Jay Khan for the past six years I
was the state senator representing Keane
and 14 other towns in Cheshire County uh
I'm still from Keene but I'm also a
member of the New Hampshire Civics board
now and this is something that I think
all of us are passionate about right
Civics education we're participants in
the process and and we are advocates for
getting more people engaged in Civics so
that's why we go to schools and
classrooms and talk about uh what we do
and why students should pay attention
and engage and talk with us because we
we need their voices and we need the
questions that they want answered so
uh I want to address first a need and
then some of the questions that have
come up but let me uh let me piggyback
off of Senator Carson's opening comments
New Hampshire depends on the citizenry
that recognizes participants are a
necessary part of our government and
Society in this state
and consider this about our state we
have 430 elected officials we have
234 towns each with 3 to 15 select
persons or counselors they each have
planning boards they have a conservation
commissions we have 234 libraries in the
state and each of those have advisory
committees and governing issues
195 school districts each of those
depend on volunteers as their governance
for their governance structure we have a
very reliable election system in the
state and the Secretary of State tells
me that there are seven thousand
individuals that make sure that those
elections are safe and secure and act
produce accurate results
there are not-for-profits in this state
that number over
6500 in this state each of those boards
has a board of directors maybe on
average 10 65
000 volunteers leading those those
boards
there was 6 500 boards contribute to the
economy of this of our state
11 billion dollars a year
our state employee our state as a whole
employs uh people in government state
and local uh some federal 84
000 people that's 13 percent of New
Hampshire's Workforce
uh we know that in New Hampshire's
government we have ten thousand
positions 10 percent of which are vacant
and the vacancy rates in our
municipality workforces are about equal
um
this is a state with less than 1.4
million people where 25 percent of its
Workforce is in government or non-profit
organizations and another 330
000 volunteers are volunteering for
those uh in other government or uh
not-for-profit organizations and then we
know that somewhere around half of our
the people in the State uh don't know
our branches of government
uh so we have
a goal it's real clear what our goals
are in this state and and how the state
functions uh it's dependent on an
Engaged citizenry uh but uh clearly we
aren't giving the tools to all people to
be part of that engagement and that's
what this bill is about and it's not
about doing it one time which is what
our statute right now requires
uh and the thank goodness it does
Mr chairman
um but
the idea behind this bill is to make
sure that there is a spiraling
curriculum something that can build upon
previous engagement and knowledge and
that it spirals through from
kindergarten through eighth grade into
high school and into adult life
because that's how we're going to be
successful as a state and engaging more
citizens
um
not only need to understand our rights
but we also need to understand what our
responsibilities of citizens in our
state and in our nation the choir of us
um
representative McConnell McDonald thank
you for your question earlier uh you
said if you understand it are you more
likely to participate I think we've
gotten the answer today uh and and you
may wonder what does participation look
like in a classroom when you've got K
through three uh and one of the one of
the New Hampshire Civics uh uh task
forces right now is building a k-3
curriculum and one of the people on that
task force uh has written that uh you
know we vote in our classroom all the
time all you got to do is start making
the connections
do you want recess now or do you want to
read
do you want a snack now
or are we going to talk about something
in the class
um
let's take a vote on what your favorite
color is
representative lad may say it's blue I
may say it's green
representative lead and why why do you
prefer blue does it make you feel how
does it make you feel uh and and so now
you're beginning to speak about
why you prefer one thing or another this
is an engagement in a voting process you
could then take a poll in the class how
many people in here prefer green to blue
uh or blue to green
um but you see it's it's it's then the
outcome of this and understanding the
outcome and and respecting that hey
there are differences when we see things
differently and we accept those outcomes
uh these are the Civic lessons they can
get tied to uh our educational Cycles uh
and and that's how we build and engage
citizenry uh it it's when you when you
begin to understand Civics as a habit
you begin to accept those habits as your
responsibilities and voting is a habit
that we need to make a part of our
responsibilities and there are many
other Civic lessons like that
um
so uh in short uh I know that there's
some disagreement when you hear that
there's some disagreement uh uh we want
to accommodate that and trying and this
is a bill that's tried to do that uh
from its introduction in the Senate to
the amendment in the Senate that was
introduced by Senator Tim Lang a member
of your body for many years uh it it
leads to the local school districts the
choice of how they're going to teach the
content and do read the second page
because the second page of this begins
to identify very specifically what the
knowledge areas are and then you begin
to apply them and that's what the first
page asks learn the knowledge that are
the foundation of our nation our state
and our communities and then begin to
apply it
because that's sticky learning and we've
seen that in every level of Education
when you learn something and you can
apply it you are demonstrating
competency
uh so I ask uh We've we've gotten a
unanimous vote out of the Senate on this
bill uh and I hope that we can get a
similar kind of response from the house
and thank you uh members of the
committee
thank you very much we have any uh
questions for
The Honorable Jay Khan
seen none thank you very much okay thank
I think we should have had a social
studies teachers convention today
because I'm also a former social studies
teacher
um I taught seventh and 8th grade social
studies which included uh US history for
a number of years in Connecticut
um I'm also have taught school in
Michigan and I've also taught for a
number of years here in New Hampshire
kindergarten for five years so I do know
that
um
I wanted to read uh the preface of this
history book because it kind of stated
everything that has been going on and
what the twists and turns can be to
learning about Civics and histories
and it says to present the great facts
of our country's history in an
attractive and relatable form has been
the object of this work
that the history of the United States is
not more generally read arises from the
fact that the works which originally
ordinary readers find are overloaded
with details and interrupted by tedious
disquisitions others seem written from a
sectional political or other standpoint
and the writer's prejudices are thrust
before the reader at every page
the author has aimed to give the
narrative clean clearness and simplicity
and to be impartially giving each part
of the country an equal importance and
equal justice in the treatment of events
giving importance only to such as
deserve it in view of their bearing on
the whole country
A History of the United States for the
general public should be one to be read
with equal interest in every state by
persons of every age it should be as
clear as the Crystal Waters of our
purest streams as solid and impartial as
the great mountains that receives
Serenity the sunshine and the storm and
look calmly down on the quiet plain and
the thunderous cataract this value may
not fulfill all that it is aimed at or
desired but it can claim to have made a
step in the proper direction towards
affording a history of our country
readable impartial and accurate and the
copyright of this book is 1886.
so as we've heard over and over as
social studies teachers
if we don't learn our history we're
doomed to repeat it so even in 1886 when
we still only had at that point I want
to make sure I'm remembering correctly
that we only had 38 States
so we still that's why it said trying to
include all the states and all the
terror areas and
um
it's you know I've always had a love for
history this was an antique book I
picked up as a history teacher because I
was like let's see what happened how
history was written back then because it
seems to have changed
um and uh so I yes Civics needs to be
taught in the schools I'm concerned
about the same sections that Anne-Marie
were concerned about and that I think
this is a good starting point I still
think there needs to be worked on this
bill
um
and uh I keep hearing that everyone
talks about No Child Left Behind well No
Child Left Behind stopped in 2015. we've
had almost a decade
to make up for any mistake or any
misgivings from No Child Left Behind and
in the decade if that hasn't happened
then that is not should not be
the fault of a program that was over 10
years ago you've had a decade to make
changes and the Essa again did not focus
on social studies it focused on reading
and Science and Math because that's
where they want their Workforce to go
towards and
um they don't feel like Civic knowledge
needs to be there
when I did teach us history we did get
to the Constitution we went through it
it was fascinating to engage students
I'm from a family that my parents I've
known from a young age that yes you have
to be involved my mother was on this PTA
school board and just now at the age of
74 years old she stopped being a town
council member in her town so I grew up
with Civics and politics and everything
um
so
while I agree that we do have to have
cynics we also need to find a way to
take something off the teacher's plates
if you're going to require this then we
need to take something off their plates
so as a second grade teacher I had to
fit in all the reading I had to fit in
all the math I had to fit in all of the
phonics and the writing and yes we still
did handwriting when I taught second
grade
but then we had to do this whole weekly
thing almost every day about social
emotional learning well something had to
drop and yes science and social studies
had to drop a lot of times I didn't drop
it I made sure it was in my classroom
but a lot of teachers they couldn't
figure out how to fit it in because
you've got kids being pulled out for
this thing and this thing and this thing
and if you don't take something off
their plate this is still not going to
get put in there even if you pass this
law and have this requirement it's still
not going to get in the school day
because there's not enough time in the
day because you're also dealing with the
bloody nose in the corner because all of
a sudden so and so just got a bloody
nose for whatever reason or someone has
a stomach ache or you have all that and
all those little times of missing out on
learning happen and there's nothing you
can do to prevent it or the fire drill
that goes off
um so and again you know I keep hearing
about you know learning about behavior
and learning about concerns that starts
in kindergarten I mean everything you
know you learned in kindergarten and you
learned how to behave you learned how to
get along and you learn those skills in
kindergarten it sickens me that we're
talking about coding in kindergarten no
that's not what you need to learn in
kindergarten you need to learn to behave
you learn schools rules and you learn
what is acceptable in working with
others coding is not going to teach you
those skills and if you don't learn them
in kindergarten there's no way you're
going to keep on going up onto those
other grades so coding needs to get out
of kindergarten and the last thing I
have to say is I keep hearing people
talking about that our country has a
democracy we are a republic
thank you
we are a republic our founding fathers
did not trust the masses we do not rule
by masses we rule by a republic we elect
you
to represent us
and to hopefully meet our needs and then
pass laws and agree to all of that I
also grew up on Schoolhouse Rock I mean
that's where a lot of my Civic
information came from as a little kid
Saturday morning cartoons you got
inundated and you saw those Schoolhouse
Rocks over and over and over again and I
use those in my curriculum and in my
teaching because that was a way to get
to the students
but again if you want to include this
and you want a way to get this in the
classroom take something off the
teacher's plates
thank you any questions thank you any
questions from the committee
see none thank you very much all right
Republic
good afternoon Deborah has an American
Federation of teachers and I'm here to
speak in favor of Senate Bill 216 but
also you know Express a little bit of
reservation
um
my background is from teaching
Elementary so I will actually agree with
some of what the previous speaker was
saying but I'll start with the parts in
favor uh teaching Civics is very
important and it can be done at the
elementary level
um so I want to say that right off the
bat Civics is all about how we agree to
you know work together and make rules
how we influence the roles that are
being made and how whether we
participate or not those rules do apply
to us so it is important to know how
rules are made and how you can
participate in the making of them and
and shape them if you want to if you
don't agree with the rules that are
being made whether that is in your
classroom in your town in your state or
in your country so it's very important
for students to begin learning that when
they are young
in elementary school there are
opportunities to incorporate that in
other things you are doing such as your
every day you have a morning meeting in
most classrooms and there you do
um have you
you make your classroom rules and you
often will be voting on things
so you know what what role shall we have
so that we can work and learn together
without interrupting each other or
taking away from others learning so that
is one opportunity to have a small
civics lesson on a level that students
can very easily grasp
um
so that is
um you know one opportunity there are
many opportunities to work in
non-fiction reading at you know
age appropriate levels as you go through
Elementary School where you are reading
things that would be also teaching them
Civics lessons I did hear you asked the
question representative Hall about how
much time per week
I think it is much more important to
look at a series of Standards or
learning targets so that you are
teaching Civics as a
reasonable curriculum or series of goals
things you want the students to be able
to understand learn and do
um rather than so many minutes per week
because there just really is not that
much time in the school day to say you
know if I just can get 30 minutes a week
or 45 minutes a week they'll definitely
know how to do what they need to do not
necessarily
um because as you know was very well
Illustrated often things interfere and
um you won't always get everyone where
they need to be in that amount of time
or some students will be ahead of where
they need to be
so while I support what the intent of
this bill is I do have some concerns
if we pass this
we also need to be supporting
particularly our teachers in K through
five k through six with
updated social studies standards that
districts can adopt
if they want we're not mandating that
they adopt these standards but the the
learning targets that they can use so
that you will have a consistent
curriculum we need to be supporting them
with examples of the resources and
curriculums that would be appropriate
for teaching Civics particularly at
those younger grades as has pointed out
there's not a lot out there commercially
New Hampshire Historical Society has
some wonderful stuff for kind of
starting with Upper Elementary but we
need a lot of filling in that lower
elementary level and professional
development again at the elementary
level we do have some teachers who
are not confident in teaching Civics
maybe because they haven't looked at it
so much as a separate
um
discipline from what they are already
teaching yeah they're confident in
teaching math confident in teaching
reading they haven't really been asked
to teach Civics so those are my
reservations about this bill
my colleagues on the New Hampshire
Civics Learning Coalition are confident
work together to provide some resources
when this bill was first written they
always say commission attached to it who
would have helped with that information
piece but it was taken out when the bill
was amended so I guess my closing would
be
something that would make sure the
implementation of this doesn't get lost
it doesn't just get dropped with yes
we've got some wonderful ideas we think
they all should be taught you all figure
out how to do it that doesn't really
help our students in the long run
because you all figure out how to do it
ends up being oh my gosh one more thing
on my plate how does it get done
and with that
um that's all I really need to say today
I'll take questions and try to enter my
second thank you any questions from the
committee
I've seen none thank you very much for
being here
uh Kathleen Cuddy Egbert thank you for
well thank you for the opportunity to
testify today and I'll try to be brief
because I know this has been a very long
session for you and I'm not sure I'm
going to say anything that's really a
whole lot different from what you've
heard but with my experience I might be
able to affirm a few things for you
so
um as you know my name is Kathy Cudi
Egbert
I'm a recently retired superintendent
currently an education consultant
a member of the New Hampshire Civics
coalition
a member of the New Hampshire
Association of school administrators
a parent of two daughters and the wife
of a political science Professor so that
might have something to do with my
perspective
I'm here today to testify in support of
SB 216 and I I do want to make it clear
however I'm testifying on my own behalf
um and there is you've already heard
that there's broad support that this is
a nonpartisan bill so I don't need to
elaborate on that I think it's clear to
everyone that
children in the United States attend
schools across the country have a right
to a free public education and that has
everything to do with Civics
our form of government requires an
educated citizenry in order to
participate fully and to self-govern
successfully the primary purpose behind
the founding of public education
was to educate children of all walks of
life together
to develop some common knowledge and
understandings and citizenship and I
know you've heard that before but I
think it's so important that I wanted to
say it again
in recent years math literacy and
science have been the primary focus in
school and unfortunately and you've
heard this before as well that
high-stakes testing in these areas has
intensified this Focus
the result has been less time and
attention devoted to civics
educating students in math literacy and
science is necessary for an educated
citizenry but certainly not sufficient
and you've heard about all of the
reports indicating how important Civics
education is so I'm not going to go into
any of that again but I do think one of
the most important elements of SB 216 is
the fact that it elevates the importance
of civics education
with the decrease in attention to social
studies
um one of the things that has concerned
me and you've heard this before too is
the increase of incivility in our public
discourse
political polarization has made it
increasingly difficult
um for for our government to forge a
consensus about how to address our
country's many challenges the evidence
that students need to learn that
conflict is an inherent part of our
democracy and that we must help develop
the ability to weigh evidence and this
is I I think this is maybe not gotten a
lot of attention in some of the
discussion but weighing evidence
analyzing primary sources understanding
conflicting perspectives making
evidence-based arguments and especially
demonstrating a respect for complexity
and differing perspectives and engaging
in respectful dialogue now naturally
there has to be a content and knowledge
base in order to do all of that so
contrary to some of the discussion that
you heard today I believe that's implied
of course there has to be a knowledge
base
as with math literacy and science Civics
education needs to begin early
and again a little bit of a Different
Twist I Was An Early Childhood educator
that's one of the the
um areas that I taught before I became
an administrator and going through my
schools when I was a superintendent
teachers began Civics in kindergarten
with activities not not just voting on
certain things but such class rewarding
meetings lessons lessons about people in
the neighborhood and those citizens in
the neighborhood and what they
contribute to society student
responsibilities developing the
classroom and making sure that there's a
sense of community and responsibility as
students participate in that classroom
so teachers are incorporating Civics now
but I do agree that they need to do it
and
um in a more intentional and
developmentally sequenced manner there's
a lot of time spent on professional
development for reading science and math
but little time spent on professional
development for civics education I think
you've heard that you know there needs
to be resources Etc
so I I think it's the importance of
students were elevated we'd see more of
a focus on professional development and
I'm going to try to wrap this up because
I can see that you are all tired
um so in summary uh I I believe critic
of civics education is important for our
children to have the tools necessary to
sustain the democracy and and I don't
think it's too dramatic to say that our
democracy depends on it and I do support
hope that you'll support
sb216 and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you for being here
um any questions from the committee
I just have one um you mentioned that
you think there's an implied knowledge
base I do yeah
um I was looking at I don't know if you
have a copy of the bill I do I was
wondering if you think um line 21 22
under 1B
goes in the direction that you're
looking for in terms of a base knowledge
yes I yes okay yeah thank you okay
you're welcome
any further questions
see none thank you again thank you very
much
um and I believe that that is our last
no
right
yeah and it is the last bill also
um we are going to uh postpone the last
bill um we've talked to the prime
sponsor and all and uh we will put
she did not want to wait
um and I'm not sure how many of us
wanted to wait
um so uh SB 135 will be put off uh to
another date
um so with that I think we are
free for the day rest of the day
[Music]
happening